WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL%
DISTANCING AND BASS COVERING
GUIDELINES. AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL BE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. DOES PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
ALSO PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED DID
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
UNMUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME THEN YOU
ARE ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PUT PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO. TWO FOUR
SIX TWO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE FOR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE AND MUTED AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND FOR CALLING IN
TODAY. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
AND I DON'T EXPECT THAT TO
HAPPEN TO THE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
VERY POLITE. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
BE HEARD AFTER ALL DISCUSSION
ITEMS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED.
LASTLY FOR EVERYONE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT HERE TODAY PLEASE KEEP
YOUR MOUTH ON COVERING YOUR NOSE
AND MOUTH AT ALL TIMES. BEFORE
WE BEGIN. LET TO STAB ISSUE
QUORUM MISS WHEN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR CAFIERO CARE ABERA
HERE SENATOR NIELSEN. SENATOR
COME LONGER. WE HAVE A QUORUM IT
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING ALL THE ISSUES LISTED
IN THE DISCUSSION SECTION OF THE
AGENDA TOGETHER. SO IF YOU KNOW
WE HAVE- AN AGENDA THERE ARE
SOME ITEMS THAT ARE UP FOR VOTE
ONLY WILL TAKE THOSE UP AT THE
END AFTER WE'VE HEARD PUBLIC
COMMENT. RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS START WITH THE ITEMS
THAT ARE OPEN FOR DISCUSSION.
AND WE'LL START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION CD TFA. I WILL
START WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S
TESTIMONY. HI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HELLO THE TRICK CABALLERO
INTERESTING TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I'M CHASING OUT THE CFO
OF THE CD TFA I'M JOINED BY OUR
DIRECTOR NICK INTEREST AS WELL
AS A FEW OTHER SENIOR LEADERS
I'M SO THE I. P. C. P. AFTER
DISCUSSION IS R. E. CIGARETTES-
TAXED- THE BACKGROUND IS THAT-
IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR SB THREE
NINETY FIVE. I'M WAS PASSED
WHICH CREATES A NEW TAX ON E.
CIGARETTES- THAT'S EFFECTIVE-
THIS JULY FIRST I'M TO FUND THIS
NEW TAX PROGRAM CD TFA REQUESTS
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION AND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION IN TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AND I'M GOING. ON
THE REQUEST WILL FIND A NEW
POSITIONS AND ALSO EXISTING
STAFF TIME- ON THE NEW TAX
PROGRAM. THE OF THE NEW TOWN
THAT IS FORECASTED- SEVENTEEN
MILLION THIS YEAR TO HAPPIER-
AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION I AND-
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE FOR
THE WHOLE YEAR- THE BUDGET
REQUEST WOULD BE FUNDED BY THE
NEW ON YOU TAX THE CIGARETTES
SPECIAL TAX FUND. ON AND SINCE
THIS IS A NEW- TAX PROGRAM AS
PART OF THE SP THREE NINETY FIVE
THE GENERAL FUND A LOAN TO THREE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE E.
CIGARETTE SPECIAL TAX FUND. TO
PROGRAM THE NEW TAX INTO OUR-
REVENUE I. T. SYSTEM AND ALSO TO
DESIGN THE NEW TAX RETURN- AND
REACH OUT TO TAXPAYERS. THAT'S
THE OVER YOU I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. LIKE TO SEE IF
FIVE FINANCE WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON DIXON'S DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE SUPPORT CD TFA IS
PROPOSAL. VERY GOOD HOW ABOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
ANY COMMENTS. SAYS KIRSTEN WITH
THE L. A. WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THE PROPOSAL. VERY GOOD- I
LIKE TO OPEN THE DISCUSSION
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR NIELSEN NO
QUESTIONS I HAVE NO QUESTIONS
THIS IS AN ITEM THAT WE WILL BE
HOLDING OPEN SO WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
CRUCIATUS- AND- WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ONTO THE NEXT. ITEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE NEXT ITEM IS
ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN WHICH IS
THE BOND ALLOCATION PROGRAM
WORKLOAD AND- THE THIS WILL BE
PRESENTED. BY THE DEPARTMENT-
THE CALIFORNIA DEBT LIMIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE. I THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE THIS IS
NANCY ROWE BLESS I'M SPEAKING
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEBT LIMIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE. WE ARE
REQUESTING THAT GENERAL FUND AND
ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR THE
INCREASED WORKLOAD THAT WE HAVE
AT THE DEBT LIMIT ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE. AS YOU KNOW- WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATH
ALLOCATION FOR THE STATE'S
CEILING CAP ON. ALL BOND IS
ALREADY FOR CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE
ENTERED INTO AN EXTREMELY
COMPETITIVE PROCESS FOR BOND
ALLOCATION WHERE WERE
OVERSUBSCRIBED THREE TIMES. AND
WITH SUCH RESPONSIBILITY. AND
WE'VE ALSO DISCOVERED THAT NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFFING. THAT
YOU CONCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY I
GUESS VERY GOOD. BERMAN A
FINANCE ANY COMMENT. PARTITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCED WITH
NOTHING TO ADD. ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. IN
THIS ROW WITH THE L. A. L. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL VERY GOOD ON
SATURDAY NIELSEN ANY QUESTIONS.
A NO QUESTIONS I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE AND THEIR RELATED TO- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THIS PARTICULAR
BUDGET ITEM IS RELATED TO
COMPLIANCE IS THAT CORRECT. I
COMPLIANCE IT WOULD BE THE NEXT
ITEM FOR THE TAX CREDIT. THIS IS
FOR BOND ALLOCATION. AND THIS IS
FOR- ED TAX EXEMPT BONDS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. RIGHT SO
THIS THIS REQUEST IS NOT
NECESSARILY REGARDING THE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CONDITIONS
FOR WHICH THE BONDS ARE ARE ARE
ISSUED OR THAT THE GRANTS ARE
ISSUED FROM THE BOND. IT
CERTAINLY IS- BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
A JOINTS- APPLICATION PROCESS SO
WITH THAT BOND ALLOCATION IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE TAX CREDITS YOU
HAVE TO APPLY FOR A BOND TO
RECEIVE TAX CREDITS- BUT THE
PARTICULAR ISSUE WITH-
COMPLIANCE AND THE STAFFING
NEEDED FOR THAT IS WITHIN THEIR
TAX CREDIT. AN ALLOCATION
COMMITTEE ARCHIVE VERY GOOD ALL
ASPECTS THE QUESTIONS AND FOR
THE NEXT THAT IDENTITY OKAY WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS A
WHOLE OPEN ITEM SO WE WILL HOLD
IT OPEN AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THAT ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN WHICH
IS AGAIN THAT CALIFORNIA TAX
CREDIT ALLOCATION COMMITTEE BUT
IT'S DEVELOPMENT AND COMPLIANCE
SECTIONS WORKLOAD INCREASE.
CORRECT SO IT MEANS YOU'RE A
LIST AGAIN I'M ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE TAX
CREDIT. ALLOCATIONS AND THE
REQUEST. BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
ALSO TRADITIONAL PASSWORD WE-
YOU KNOW LIKE I MENTIONED IN THE
DALLAS CATION COMMITTEE. AND WE
ARE IN A IN AN EXTREMELY
COMPETITIVE PROCESS THESE TAX
CREDITS ARE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE KNOW THAT THAT- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
INITIATIVES. AND IN OUR- YOU
KNOW IT ATTEMPTS TO ALLOCATE ALL
OF THE FUNDING THAT WE CAN TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT WE ALSO
ALLOCATE TAX CREDITS WHICH
CREATES. AN EQUITY POSITION FOR
DEVELOPERS TO BE ABLE TO-
PRODUCED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITHIN CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH
THAT COMES THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
COMPLIANCE MONITORING OF THOSE
PROPERTIES FOR FIFTY FIVE YEARS.
SO IN THIS COMPETITIVE
ENVIRONMENT WE'VE BEEN AND-
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
PROPERTIES THAT WE HAVE TO
MONITOR BY ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
PER YEAR WE ALREADY HAVE OVER
FIVE THOUSAND PROPERTIES. SO
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED PROPERTIES
THAT EVERY THREE YEARS WE NEED
TO DO PHYSICAL. INSPECTIONS OF
THE PROPERTIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE COMPLIANT WITH THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING REQUIREMENTS
THAT THEY ORIGINALLY APPLIED. I
HAVE FOR THE TAX CREDITS. AND
WE'RE FINDING IT SAYS YOU KNOW
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO MEET OUR
IRS MANDATE TO INSPECT ALL OF
THESE PROPERTIES WE DO A
PHYSICAL INSPECTION AND ALSO
IT'S FILE INSPECTION OF ALL OF
THESE PROPERTIES AND- IT YOU
KNOW WE ARE BEHIND THIS YEAR
BECAUSE OF CODED WE WERE GIVEN A
RELEASE FROM THE IRS DO NOT HAVE
TO BE THIS IS FILE INSPECTION
HOWEVER IT DOES NOT RELIEVE US
GOING FORWARD AND- AND- WE STILL
HAVE TO SEE THOSE PARTICULAR
PROPERTY SO BASICALLY WILL JUST
BE A YEAR BEHIND FROM. THIS
POINT GOING FORWARD. AND WE'VE
ALSO BEEN TASKED WITH- AND
DISASTER CREDITS WHICH- HELP- AT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
IN THE AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY WILDFIRES. AND WE'VE
ALSO BEEN TASKED WITH A
HISTORICAL CREDIT- INITIATIVE
THAT WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
OFFICE OF HISTORIC PRESERVATION
WE'RE DEVELOPING A PROGRAM FOR
TAX CREDITS FOR THAT AS WELL SO
THE- A PORTION OF THE STAFF THAT
WE'RE REQUESTING IS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THOSE PROGRAMS
AND A PORTION IS FOR THE
COMPLIANCE. VERY GOOD- IT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. THE CHANT
DEPARTMENTAL FINANCE ARE WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
. VERY GOOD ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS TO RAISE- REGARDING
THE- WORKLOAD DEMANDS ASSISTING
WITH THE PROPOSAL- GOOD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THING
NINE- IF THEY BEAT IT I THINK
YOU PROBABLY ANSWERED THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD AN IN AND
OUT- D. COMPLIANCE REQUIREMENTS
ARE THOSE THAT ARE IMPOSED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY. VERY GOOD AND- AND
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT- THAT
SOME OF THEM HAVE TO IS THAT
SOME OF THE COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS REQUIRE IN PERSON-
INSPECTION AND SO THAT SAM.
UNDERSTOOD IT'S UNDERSTOOD HOW
IMPORTANT THAT THAT BECOMES AS
WELL AND THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE IF THE
UNITS ARE ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I APPRECIATE. VERY
GOOD ALL RIGHTY. I THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN ITEM. SO WE WILL WE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR. FOR THAT AT
THE THOSE REPORTS- MOVING ON AND
APARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION IN INNOVATION. AND
THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
BANKING OPTION ACT. TURN IT OVER
TO THE DEPARTMENT. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS APRIL ELEVENTH I MET.
CHIEF OF THE FISCAL MANAGEMENT
OFFICE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AND
INNOVATION. AND WITH ME TODAY IS
NICOLE HE'S TO TELL ME OUR
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF
LEGISLATION. BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
B. CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BANKING
OPTION ACT WORKLOAD B. C. P. AT
RELATED TO AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. I AB ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
ESTABLISHED THAT CAL I COUNTED
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION WHICH IS
TASKED WITH COMPLETING A MARKET
ANALYSIS ON THE CAL ACCOUNTS
PROGRAM. WHICH IS ALSO DUE TO
THE LEGISLATURE BY JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THIS PROGRAM
WOULD PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS WITH
A NO COST CHECKING ACCOUNTS. DFP
I CAN. OR THEIR DESIGNEES WILL
HAVE TO SPEND A CONSIDERABLE
TIME ON THE COMMISSION AND AT
BOARD MEETINGS. HARTMAN IS
REQUESTING ONE POSITION AND TWO
YEARS OF FUNDING. AT TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN THE SECOND YEAR SO THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY PARTICIPATE IN THE
STUDY UNDER AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL. VERY GOOD- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. CHARLIE MANNING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT THIS REQUEST
WILL ALLOW THE FBI TO
EFFECTIVELY SHARE ITS EXPERTISE
AND GUIDANCE AS A REGULATOR OF
FINANCIAL SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THE
CALLACHAN BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
AND PROVIDE VALUABLE INPUT ON
THE EVALUATION OF THE MARKET
ANALYSIS. DATA AND RESULTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH HOW
ABOUT THE L. A. O. ANY COMMENTS
. PETER IS WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE HAVEN'T
RAISED ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- COMMITTEE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SEEING
NONE I DO HAVE A QUESTION- AND I
AND I. IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THIS
IS A POSITION TO BE ABLE TO
ATTEND THE COMMISSION MEETING.
AND- IT JUST ODD THAT. THE
COMMISSION WILL TAKE UP SO MUCH
WORK THAT OR TAKE UP SO MUCH
TIME THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
STAFF MEMBER. DESIGNATED FROM MY
AGE PART DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION INNOVATION THIS IS
THE WORK THIS IS WHAT THEY DO
SOMEONE DURING. THE EXPLAIN TO
ME WHY IT WE NEED AN EXTRA
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO. TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE COMMISSION
WE- THE WORK IS GOING TO BE DONE
THROUGH THE TREASURER'S OFFICE.
AND I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY
YOU NEED AN EXTRA POSITION. IT'S
MINOR BUT IT IT. YOU KNOW AS WE
AS WE MOVE ALONG THE MORE WE
GROW GOVERNMENT THE- MORE IT
COSTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION AND CHAIRWOMAN
CABALLERO AND I'D LIKE TO. ASK
NICOLE HE SAID TELL ME TO SPEAK
TO SOME OF THE DETAILS- SHE'S
OUR SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT AND
WORKS VERY CLOSELY. WITH AT
LEGISLATURE ON THIS BILL NICOLE
. SENATOR AND MAYBE- WHEN THIS
BELT WAS GOING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE- WE WERE. ASKED BY
THE RESPECTIVE COMMITTEE- TO
PROVIDE HER EXPERTISE IN
REGULATING BANKS AND- FINANCIAL
SERVICES IN GENERAL AND SO WE
ENVISION THAT THIS ATTORNEY OUR
DISPOSITION WILL BE ABLE TO
COMPARE AND ATTEND MEETINGS AS
YOU HAVE NOTED- ENGAGE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO GATHER
INFORMATION FROM PEOPLE THAT WE
MAY REGULATE OR OTHERS OUTSIDE
OF OUR PURVIEW- I ATTEND THE
MEETINGS AND PREPARE FOR TO
HELP. OUR CONTRACT WITH A VENDOR
WHO WILL DO THE STUDY- AND
PROVIDE THE LEVEL PROVIDE
EXPERTISE FROM OUR DEPARTMENT AT
TO THAT COMMITTEE ABOUT. OKAY I
STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
IT I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY- STILL HAVE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT BUT THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN ITEM SO I'M SURE WHAT
WILL BE BACK TO HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT. SO WILL
WILL- WILL HOLD IT OPEN. MOVEON
TO ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN. ON
THESE ISSUES ARE IN THE- THE
PARK DEPARTMENT OF THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD AND ISSUE NUMBER
SIXTEEN IS THE ENTERPRISE DATA
TO REVENUE PROJECT TOO SO IF WE
GET OUT- THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
. THAT. I COULD AFTERNOON JAMIE
HARRIMAN FRANCHISE TAX BOARD OF
TV'S FIRST PROPOSAL FOR TODAY IS
RELATED TO YOUR TO DO LIST NOTED
. THE START OF FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE WE'LL
SEE IF TO BE ENTERING THE SECOND
YEAR OF THE UTR TO PROJECT
OFFERED. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
BUILD ON THE FOUNDATIONS THAT BY
EDR FOR CENTRALIZING TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTION SUPPORTING KEY BUSINESS
FUNCTIONS. EASIER TO BUILT ON
THIS PLATFORM BY EXPANDING
ENTERPRISE CASE MANAGEMENT AND
MODELING SERVICES FOR AUDIT.
FINDING FOR SPENT AN ACCOUNT
RECEIVABLE ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS
EXPANDING OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE
TOOLS INCLUDING THE TAXPAYER
FOLDER EXTERNALLY KNOWN AS MY
FTP. THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTED
AUGMENTATION OF ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE POINT ONE MILLION FOR
THE SECOND YEAR PRO THE PROJECT.
THAT PREDOMINANTLY IS FOR THE
VENDOR COMPENSATION PAYMENT OF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION. BUT ALSO INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR TWENTY PERMANENT
POSITIONS TWENTY THREE AND A
HALF FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
POSITIONS LIMITED TERM AND
TWENTY ONE PERMANENT ENEMY
POSITIONS. FOLLOWING THE
STATEWIDE PROCESS ESTABLISHED TO
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR LARGER
PROJECTS AN ANNUAL B. C. P. IS
REQUIRED FOR NEW COSTS RELATED
TO THAT SPECIFIC YEAR MUCH AS
YOU SEE DISPLAYED IN THIS
CURRENT PROPOSAL. COSTS WITHIN
THIS B. C. B. CAN BE ONGOING
LIMITED TERM OR ONE TIME AS
NOTED WITHIN THE NARRATIVE
ITSELF. ALSO FOR TRANSPARENCY
PURPOSES A NEW THIS YEAR FTV HAS
CLICKED INCLUDED A NOTATION IN
THE P. C. P. WORKLOAD MEASURES
DOCUMENT FOR OUT YOUR RESOURCES.
FOR LIKE ACTIVITIES THAT WILL
REQUESTED IN LATER YEARS. MOST
NOTABLY THE SYNTAX WORKS
OFFICIALLY WITH TRAINING DATA
CONVERSION AND MODELING
RESOURCES. DURING THE SECOND AIR
ACTUALLY IS REQUESTING RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT VARIOUS STAGES OF
WEBSITE ENHANCEMENTS MODELING.
EDUCATION OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS AND
ENHANCED DATA CAPTURE. WE WILL
ALSO BE CONTINUING TO LOOK FOR
FUNDING FOR TRAINING SECURITY
CHANGE MANAGEMENT HR MATTERS
DATA MANAGEMENT AND OVERSIGHT
FUNCTIONS. AS STATED BEFORE THIS
PROJECT UTILIZES THE CONCEPT OF
ASKING FOR RESOURCES ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS AT THIS TIME I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. SEVEN STAR
PARTNER FINANCE WE SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL. VERY GOOD HOW ABOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
. BRING WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS ITEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY VERY GOOD- LET ME JUST SAY
THAT- WHILE I APPRECIATE THIS
IS- A FAIRLY EXTENSIVE B. C. P-
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS DONE
A TERRIFIC JOB WITH THEIR I. T.
PROJECT IN THAT. IN THE PAST OF
THE AT OUR PROJECT- NUMBER ONE
WAS- WAS REALLY WELL DONE IT WAS
DELIVERED ON TIME AND IT
ACHIEVED. THE PURPOSES FOR WHICH
IT WAS. CONSTRUCTED AND
PURCHASED IN. BUILT IN SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE ABILITY OF A- FTV
TO GET TO GET THEIR I. T.
PROJECTS DONE WELL AND SO- I
DON'T HAVE ANY ANY CONCERNS
ABOUT IT I WANT TO SAY- THANK
YOU FOR- SETTING THIS UP SO IT
IS ON A YEARLY BASIS AND WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS
IS MOVES ALONG. THIS IS A HOLDO
OPEN ITEMS SO WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD IT OPEN AND- AND- MOVE ON
TO. ISSUE NUMBER SEVENTEEN IN
YOUR DEPARTMENT WHICH IS THE- A
SECTION FORTY ONE WORKLOAD.
THANK YOU FOR THE KIND WORDS AND
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO TAKE FOR
PRESENTATION OF THAT SECOND ITEM
. AFTERNOON THANK YOU JIM AND
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE OUR
SECOND PROPOSAL TODAY. IS TO
ACCOMMODATE THE REQUIREMENTS OF
SECTION FORTY ONE. THE REQUEST
IS FOR SIX HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND TO FUND FOR
PERMANENT POSITIONS STARTING
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AT AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
THREE THOUSAND TO FIVE ONE
ADDITIONAL POSITION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
THIS WILL ALLOW FTP TO MATCH THE
INCREASING WORKLOAD DUE TO A BOX
OF BILLS WITH THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE SECTION FORTY ONE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. THE
SECTION FORTY ONE REQUIREMENT
WAS INITIALLY ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN I REQUIRED
VARIOUS ANNUAL REPORTS FOR TAX
CREDITS. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE REQUIREMENT WAS
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE ANNUAL
REPORTS FROM ALL RELEVANT TAX
EXPENDITURES. THIS WORK REQUIRES
OF TV TO ENSURE THE RELEVANT
DATA IS ACCESSIBLE AT IN THE
DATA I THEIR VIEWS BY FTP TOOK
APART THE REQUIRED ANNUAL
REPORTS. OR THE INFORMATION IS
PROVIDED TO ANOTHER DEPARTMENT
BLESSMAN TOSSED WITH WRITING THE
REPORT ITSELF. THESE RESOURCES
WERE SURE THAT HAVE TO BE CAN
ACCOMPLISH THIS WORKLOAD TIMELY
AND WITH DUE DILIGENCE. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. VERY GOOD APART OF FINANCE
ANY CAN. WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST. YES THIS IS BRIAN WITH
THE PORT OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND- WE DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL BUT WE DID WANT TO MAKE
SOME COMMENTS CIRCLE THE- WE
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE GOOD
INFORMATION ABOUT THE TAX
PROVISIONS TO INFORM YOUR
DECISION MAKING ABOUT THESE
PROGRAMS NOW AND SIMILAR FUTURE
PROPOSALS. THE PROPOSAL- BEFORE
YOU REFLECTS ON A LARGE INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF NEW TAX CREDITS
OR ADOPTED IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
AND IT ALSO SEEMS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL CONTINUE TO
ADOPT A MORE- TAX EXPENDITURE
PROGRAMS IN THE FUTURE THEY-
BASIM FORTY CREDITS ANNUALLY SO
WE FIND THIS PROPOSAL FOR
ADDITIONAL STAFF IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE IS
REASONABLE. BY THE REQUEST ALSO
INCLUDES ONE ADDITIONAL POSITION
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AND AS WE MENTIONED
ABOVE THAT'S BASED ON ASSUMPTION
OF INCREASING WORKLOAD SO IF YOU
THINK THE LEGISLATURE WILL. DROP
SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER TAX CREDITS
FOR THE COMING YEARS YOU COULD
CONSIDER REJECTING THAT PORTION
OF THE REQUEST. VERY GOOD THAT'S
HELPFUL INFORMATION QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SAME NINE I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY I AM. MY CRYSTAL BALL
DOESN'T ALWAYS TELL ME. WHAT IS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN- THIS IS A HOLD
OPEN ITEM SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
HOLD ONTO IT- IF I HAD TO GUESS
MY GUESS WOULD BE THAT WE
WOULDN'T DO FOR ANNUALLY
BECAUSE- THIS GOOD ECONOMY IS
NOT GOING TO LAST FOREVER BUT-
AGAIN MY- CRYSTAL BALL ISN'T
ALWAYS AS GOOD AS- AS IT. COULD
BE SO WELL HOLD IT OPEN AND WILL
WILL RETURN. TO THIS AT A LATER
DATE SO OFTEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION HERE-
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN WHICH IS THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT FOSTER
USED EXPANSION. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
BE MAKING THIS PRESENTATION. YES
COOLEY WHITE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON.
THIS PROPOSAL CREATES A NEW ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR REFUNDABLE TAX
CREDIT BEGINNING IN TAX YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. FOR YOUNG
ADULTS AGE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE WE WERE IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AT ANY TIME AGE THIRTEEN
OR OLDER. IT IS MODELED AFTER
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT- THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT WAS
ENACTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND
PROVIDES A FLAT ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO FAMILIES THAT
OTHERWISE QUALIFY FOR THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT. I HAVE A
CHILD AGE FIVE OR UNDER.
SIMILARLY THIS NEW CREDIT WILL
ALSO PROVIDE A FLAT ONE THOUSAND
DOLLAR. TO YOUNG ADULTS THAT
WERE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
WOULD OTHERWISE QUALIFY FOR THE
EITC. CREDIT IS INDEXED TO
INFLATION AND WILL PHASE OUT
SAME AS THE CURRENT YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT. FOSTER YOUTH AGES
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE THAT ARE
TRANSITIONING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM AND TRIBAL YOUTH THAT ARE
UNDER THE STATE'S JURISDICTION
WOULD ALSO BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
CREDIT- ALLOWED TO DULCIMER
RAISED IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
GENERALLY SUFFERED IS.
DISPROPORTIONATE LEVELS AND
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP AND POVERTY.
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE YEAR AGE
RANGE ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE POPULATION TRANSITION
IN THE WORK FORCE. THAT COULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS MEANINGFUL
CREDIT. THE CREDIT ALSO
ENCOURAGES TAX FILING WHICH IS A
KEY PART OF BUILDING GENERAL
ECONOMIC LITERACY I COULD LEAD
TO THE CLAIMING OF OTHER FEDERAL
STATE TAX BENEFITS. AMONG THIS
POPULATION. THE CREDIT WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD AND WILL REQUIRE DATA
SHARING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. WHICH WILL BE
SUBJECT TO FEDERAL APPROVAL. BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS COULD POTENTIALLY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS CREDIT. AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR TYPICAL TAPE TAKE
UP RATES AS WELL AS THE INCOME
REQUIREMENTS AND LIMITS- FOR THE
CALLIOTROPIDAE. FISCAL COST OF
THIS PROPOSALS EXPECTED TO BE
ABOUT TWENTY MILLION PER YEAR.
AND AFFECT ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS. THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY COMMENTS OR CONCERNS BY THE
L. A. O. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAD
ALAMO. LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- AS AS NOTED IN THE-
AGENDA- TROUBLING WHICH HAS NOT
YET BEEN RELEASED FOR THIS SO
WE'RE OUT HERE TO WORK WITH
STAFF ONCE THAT- LANGUAGE HAS
BEEN RELEASED TO FIND OUT MORE
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC DETAILS AND
HELP TO COMMITTEE ON THE ONLY
COMMENT WE HAD THIS IS POINTING
OUT THAT WITH US. A NEW PROGRAM
LIKE THIS- OUTRAGE WHICH HAS
BEEN A COMPONENT OF THE I. T. C.
PROGRAMMING IN THE PAST IS GOING
TO BE A KEY CONSIDERATION FO
THIS- GROUP- TARGETED HERE FOR
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH-
ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE THE FIRST
YEAR OF THE PROGRAM USES
UNKNOWN- TAKE UP WILL BE A MAJOR
QUESTION AND SO THAT COULD.
GREATLY AFFECT THE FISCAL COST
AS CURRENTLY ESTIMATED AT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS COULD ULTIMATELY
BE MORE THAN THAT OR LESS NOT
DEPENDING UPON TAKE OFF ON THE
STROKE. VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE I DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS TO ME JUST SAY THAT I-
THIS IS REALLY AN INNOVATIVE
AND- UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY I THINK
TO HELP SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE- INDIVIDUALS THAT
THAT COME THROUGH OUR SYSTEM
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN-
THE END UP AS FOSTER KIDS NOT
BECAUSE OF. SOMETHING THEY DID
BUT BECAUSE OF AN INABILITY OF
THE FAMILY REALLY TO. TO BE ABLE
TO RAISE THEM AND- SO I'M REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS AS A- AS A AS
A PILOT PROJECT- THE QUESTIONS I
HAVE I THINK PROBABLY GET
ANSWERED ONCE WE HAVE SOME
LANGUAGE. THAT WOULD DESCRIBE.
HOW FOSTER KIDS WITH ACCESS R.
FOUGHT FOSTER INDIVIDUALS WITH
ACCESS THE RESOURCES- AND SO THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE ARE THINGS
LIKE- IS THERE IS THERE THE
ABILITY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO BE ABLE TO.
SEND NOTICES- TO THE
INDIVIDUALS- THAT MIGHT BE
ELIGIBLE SO THAT WERE REALLY. WE
HAVE A MUCH. BETTER. FRAMEWORK
OR- DATABASE I GUESS IS THE BEST
WAY TO PUT IT OUGHT TO BE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE AND I SAY
THAT BECAUSE THAT HE AYE TCS
REALLY BEEN SLOW ON THE UPTAKE
IN TERMS OF FAMILIES THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE IT'S BEEN HARD TO- TO
ACCESS. THE RESOURCES IF YOU
DON'T KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
AVAILABLE FOR YOU AND SO- I'M
I'M I THINK WE'RE GONNA NEED
SOME MORE INFORMATION SO WE HAVE
A REALLY GOOD UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW THIS- TAX CREDIT WOULD WORK.
HOW AN INDIVIDUAL WOULD. BE
IDENTIFIED THE RICH COULD YOU
SELF IDENTIFY AM A FOSTER CHILD
AND SO I'M- I'M STILL NOT A
BEIJING I'M IRISH I AM ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS MONEY- ALL THE DETAILS
OF THAT I THINK ARE GOING TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I WANT TO
ASK- AND- FINANCE TO TELL US
NOW- I EXPECT IT WILL GET SOME
LANGUAGE IN WILL HAVE A BETTER
IDEA ON HOW THIS WOULD WORK BUT
I THINK IT'S A REALLY UNIQUE
AND- INTERESTING IDEA AND I AM.
I AM I'M IN SUPPORT THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN ITEMS SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HOLD IT OPEN WILL.
LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE AND- AND
SEE IF THERE ARE WAYS FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO WORK MAYBE THIS THIS-
WORKS ALONGSIDE THE EITC- AND WE
CAN USE THE FRAMEWORK. OF THE
RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE BY THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ON THE EITC
PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN. MAKE IT
MUCH MORE- WIDELY USED I THINK
THAT THE ISSUE IS THAT IF THE IF
WE CREATE A PROGRAM. AND IT'S A
PROGRAM TO HELP REDUCE POVERTY.
AND ONLY A PERCENTAGE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
ACT ACTUALLY CAN ACCESS THAT.
THEY WERE NOT MEETING THE
MANDATE WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THAT WERE REDUCING
POVERTY EVERYWHERE EVERYWHERE
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME.
COMMUNITIES THAT JUST DON'T GET
INFORMATION BECAUSE OF LANGUAGE
ISSUES AND- ISOLATION ISSUES
AND- AND THE LACK OF. OF
INFORMATION SERVICES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY SO I THINK YOU FOR
THAT REPORT AND- HE SAID AS I
SAID THIS ISA HOLD OPEN ITEM
AND- WILL BE BACK TO TALK ABOUT
THIS A LITTLE BIT MORE. I'M
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
NINETEEN THIS IS THE YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT CHANGES. AND AGAIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
GOING TO BE PRESENTING IS THAT
CORRECT. YES THAT'S CORRECT A
GOOD. HI THIS IS ROBIN FINISHED
OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET CREATED THE Y. C. T. C.
TO HELP LIFT YOUNG CHILDREN OUT
OF POVERTY THIS CREDIT PROVIDES
IN MOST CASES ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO EVERY HOUSEHOLD IN
THE OTHERWISE QUALIFIES FOR THE
COUNTY I PC AND HAS A CHILD AGE
FIVE OR YOUNGER THE Y. C. T. C.
CURRENTLY REQUIRES RECIPIENTS TO
HAVE AT LEAST ONE DOLLAR EARNED
INCOME EARNED INCOME IS ALL
INCOME FROM BOTH EMPLOYMENT AND
SELF EMPLOYMENT INCLUDING WAGES
SALARIES TIPS. AND OTHER
COMPENSATION FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TAX YEAR OVER FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
TAXPAYERS CLAIM THIS CREDIT THE
FIRST COMPONENT OF THIS PROPOSAL
BEGINNING WITH TAX YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TO REMOVE THE ONE DOLLAR
REQUIREMENT ALLOWS HOUSEHOLDS
WITH NO EARNED INCOME OR
NEGATIVE EARNED INCOME TO CLAIM
THE Y. C. T. C. IF THEY
OTHERWISE QUALIFY FOR THE COUNTY
IG CITY. SO I CTC IS DESIGNED TO
ELIMINATE CHILD POVERTY RATHER
THAN AS AN INCENTIVE TO WORK AND
THEREFORE IT MAKES POLICY SENSE
TO EXTEND THIS BENEFIT FAMILIES
WITH NO INCOME TO REMEDIATE
CHILD POVERTY REQUIRING EARNINGS
EXCLUDES PARENTS WHOSE NEED TO
CARE FOR THEIR CHILD PREVENTS
THEM FROM MAINTAINING A JOB AS
WELL AS THOSE THAT CANNOT FIND.
CHILD CARE TO RETAIN A JOB.
FAMILIES WITH YOUNG THAT HAVE-
AND ARE JUST AS DESERVE OF
WRIST. THE CITIES. AS FAMILIES
WITH AN- THIS IS. OF HE T. C.
EXPECT TO REDUCE GENERAL FUND
REVENUES BY FIFTY FIVE MILLION
PER YEAR BEGINNING IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
AND PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS. THE
SECOND COMPONENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL INDEXES THE ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR AND CHILD TAX
CREDIT FOR INFLATION. STARTING
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TAX YEAR
TO PREVENT INFLATION FROM
ERODING THE VALUE OF THIS
IMPORTANT TAX CREDIT. FOR
FAMILIES WITH YOUNG CHILDREN.
THIS CHANGE WOULD BE CONSISTENT
WITH HOW BOTH THE STATE AND
FEDERAL IRAQI CITIES WHICH ARE
BOTH INDEX TRANSLATIONS. ARE
ADMINISTERED. OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND FAMILIES WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
CHANGE. THE PROPOSAL IS EXPECTED
TO INCREASE PERSONAL INCOME TAX
REVENUES BY NINETEEN MILLION IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND FIFTY ONE
MILLION ANDTWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. THE PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
A FIXTURE CAL IN NINETEEN SHE
COMES OUT. TO AVOID THE FULL ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR Y. C. T. C.
BEING ELIMINATED FOR A ONE
DOLLAR INCREASE IN INCOME. THE
STATE'S EITC PHASES OUT
INCREMENTALLY AS INCREASE INCOME
INCREASES BEYOND SPECIFIED
LEVELS. THE EITC WAS EXPANDED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TO INCREASE ITS
MAXIMUM A LITTLE FEES THAT RANGE
OF THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
TAX YEARS TWENTY NINETEEN. TO
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WHICH WAS
INTENDED TO ALIGN WITH EARNINGS
FOR A FULL TIME WORKER AT
MINIMUM WAGE WHICH WILL BE
FIFTEEN DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO. I IMPORTANT AN INVERSE
DRAFTING. LED TO THE E. I. T. C.
PHASING OUT ANNOUNCED RATE IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND THE FOR
MAXIMUM ELIGIBLE INCOME WOULD BE
AROUND THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS RATHER THAN THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WAS
INTENDED FOR TAX YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
YOUR QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
L. A. O. AS I DON'T KNOW WITHOUT
LETTING US OFF THERE'S NO
SPECIFIC COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
ASIDE FROM SIMILARLY I WILL BE-
WAITING FOR TRAILER BILL TO BE
RELEASED TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF
AND LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL IN DETAIL. VERY GOOD.
SHE DID IT. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THING NO
QUESTIONS ARE THIS IS AN ITEM
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD OPEN SO
WE'LL BE LOOKING FOR THE
LANGUAGE AS WELL BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR- TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY VERY HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTANDING THE ISSUE WHERE TO
MOVE ON TO ISSUE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY. WHICH IS THE S. B.
FORTINO NINE REPORT IN MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT'S GOING TO BE
DONE BY THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
. YES GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MY
NAME IS JEANNIE HERMAN AS
MENTIONED EARLIER WITH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. LAST YEAR
AFTER HE WAS ASKED TO CONDUCT A
STUDY ON OUTREACH METHODS AND
OTHER OPTIONS TO REFINING
BARRIERS TO ENSURE CALIFORNIANS
ELIGIBLE. FOR CAL E. I. T. C.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CLAIM THIS
FINANCIAL RESOURCE. BEFORE I
BEGIN A REVIEW I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR MANY PARTNERS IN
THIS EFFORT WHICH INCLUDED MANY
COMMUNITY BASED ADVOCATES AS
WELL AS OUR PEERS STATE AGENCIES
THIS REPORT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
AS COMPREHENSIVE OR COMPLETE
WITHOUT THEIR INPUT AND SUPPORT.
AND WE'RE VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THEIR PARTNERSHIP. BUT THE TALKS
HERE TO PUT TWENTY TWENTY TALK
SHARE WHICH WAS JUST FILED AND
PROCESSED. ALMOST FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIANS CLAIM
TO CALLI AKC RECEIVING FUNDS OF
ONE POINT TWO SIX BILLION. FOR
THE CALI ATC IN YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT AND ALL OF THEM ARE
LIKELY ELIGIBLE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT UNDER THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PROGRAM.
FOR JUMPING INTO THE REPORT THE
WAY WE STRUCTURED IT IS
PREDOMINATELY ON TABLES ONE TWO
AND THREE PROVIDES YOU AN ENTRY
LEVEL AND STOCKS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROGRAM
SINCE ITS INCEPTION. ON PAGES
SEVEN EIGHT THESE TABLES ARE
PRESENTED AND PROVIDE KEY
HISTORICAL INFORMATION ON THE
CAL EITC PROGRAM AND ALLOW
FOUNDATIONAL UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS PROGRAM SO THAT ANY
CONCEPTS PURSUED TO ENHANCE THE
PROGRAM. CANBE VIEWED THROUGH
THE LENS OF HOW TO ENHANCE THESE
METRICS. HISTORICAL START SHOW
THAT ALMOST 80% OF THE CALLIE
ATC CREDITS CLAIMED WERE FOR TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS OR LESS. ALMOST
75% OF THOSE CLAIMS. RESULTED IN
A SINGLE TAX FILER WITH NO
DEPENDENTS CLAIMED. ABOUT 11% OF
THOSE CLAIMING THE KELLY ATC
ALSO QUALIFIED AND CLAIMED THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT. NOT
DIVING INTO THE REPORT ITSELF
CONCEPTS WERE DEVELOPED AFTER
LISTEN SOLICITING AND EVALUATING
AND CLICK FROM NEARLY FIFTY
DIFFERENT NONPROFIT STAKEHOLDERS
ADVOCATES INTERESTED PARTIES AND
OTHER GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES.
YOU'LL KNOW WHEN READING THE
REPORT THAT THERE WAS PURPOSELY
NO RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT
AS TO WHICH CONTACTS COULD OR
SHOULD BE DONE. AS WE RESEARCH
THE CONCEPT BECAME CLEAR THAT
THERE ARE BENEFITS AND RISKS THE
TAXPAYERS IN THE STATE THAT
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO DISCUSSION
PRIOR TO MOVING FORWARD WITH
ANYONE CONCEPT. ADDITIONALLY
THERE ARE PROPOSALS THAT SHOULD
BE REVIEWED FURTHER THROUGH A
LEGAL LENS TO ENSURE THAT PRIOR
TO PURSUIT IT IS UNDERSTOOD IF
ANY LEGAL THEORIES EXIST. UNDER
FACT CAN BE OVERCOME TO PROTECT
BOTH THE TAXPAYERS THE STATE AND
ANY STUFF FOR VOLUNTEERS THAT
WOULD ENGAGE IN ANY. OF THESE
PROPOSED NEW WORK EFFORTS. I
HAVE TO BE TO THE APPROACH OF
CREATING A COPPER. LISTING OF
THESE BENEFITS RISK AND LEGAL
CONCERNS. AS WELL AS NINETEEN
ADMINISTRATING TIGHT AND
MINISTRY OF TYPE ISSUES SUCH AS
RESOURCES NEEDED OR PROPOSED
TIMING FOR IMPLEMENTATION. THAT
WILL SUPPORT A COMPREHENSIVE
DISCUSSION ON WHAT TO PURSUE HOW
TO PURSUE IT AND WHEN IT IS MOST
FEASIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTATION. SO
LET'S TAKE A SHORT WALK THROUGH
EACH CONCEPT. CONCEPT EIGHT
DEALS WITH THE SUGGESTION TO
IMPLEMENT A SIMPLIFIED FILING
PORTAL AFTER BE ASSIGNED OF
FILING PORTAL IN PLACE IN SOME
FORM SINCE THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS. CAL FILE ALLOWS MANY
TAXPAYERS TO FILE A TAX RETURN
FOR CALIFORNIA FOR FREE. IN MANY
SITUATIONS BUT NOT ALL CAL AHEC
FOLLOWS WILL QUALIFY WITH FEW IF
ANY EXCEPTIONS FOR THIS FREE
SERVICE. HOW FILE DOES ONLY
ALLOW FUTURE CAL FILE DOES ALLOW
FOR THE PRE POPULATION OF WAGE
DATA DEPENDING ON WHEN THE
TAXPAYER ATTEMPTS TO FOLLOW
RETURNS ON WHETHER THEY
REGISTERED TO USE THE
APPLICATION IN CONCERT WITH MY
FTP. LIKE ALL SECTIONS OF THIS
PAPER THIS SECTION PROVIDES A
HISTORY A DESCRIPTION OF THE
CONCEPT AND ADDRESS BENEFIT FROM
RISK BARRIERS ADDRESSED AND
MINISTRY OF ITEMS SUCH AS COSTS
AND TIME NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT.
IMPORTANT GAPS UNDERSTAND A
FURTHER PURSUIT OF THIS CONCEPT
IS DESIRED IS THAT WILL NOT
PROVIDE A SOLUTION FOR FILING A
FEDERAL TAX RETURN. TAXPAYERS
WOULD STILL NEED TO BE
ENCOURAGED TO FOLLOW FEDERAL
RETURN TO CLAIM THEM FEDERAL
INCENTIVES. ADDITIONALLY AS
POSSIBLE THAT OTHER EXISTING
FREE SERVICES AND ACTUALLY HOP
GREATER VALUE TO TAXPAYERS. FOR
PURPOSES OF FILING BOTH THE
FEDERAL AND STATE TAX RETURN
FREEZE. AND IN SOME SITUATIONS
GIVING THE ALL IMPORTANT ADVANCE
PAYMENT OF A TAX REFUND WHICH IS%
WE UNDERSTAND VERY IMPORTANT TO
TAXPAYERS. CONCEPT BE ADDRESS
THE CONCEPT OF PRE POPULATING
TAX RETURNS IN USING DATA FROM
OUR PEER ORGANIZATIONS TO
ENHANCE OUR ABILITY TO IDENTIFY.
ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS FOR CAL THANK
YOU SEE. HAVE TO BE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH SELECT YOUR
AGENCIES UNDERSTAND THE DATA
THEY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. WE'D LIKE TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PEERS AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
FOR ENGAGING WITH F. T. B. AS WE
STUDY THESE IMPORTANT CONCEPTS.
TABLE SEVEN EIGHT AND NINE ON
PAGES TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
FIVE THE REPORT SUMMARIZE OUR
FINDINGS. WE DID FIND THAT THE
DATASETS OWN BUYER PAYER
ORGANIZATIONS DID IN FACT HAVE
VALUE TO IDENTIFY WHO'S WHO. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY AFTER HE WAS NOT
ABLE TO IDENTIFY A MECHANISM TO
BRIDGE THE DEFINITIONAL OR DATA
CAPS ASSOCIATED WITH HOUSEHOLD
UNITS. WHICH ARE APPLICABLE FOR
PUBLIC SERVICE PROGRAMS. AND TAX
FILING UNIT WHICH IS APPLICABLE
FOR FILING A TAX RETURN. THE
DEFINITION OF A HOUSEHOLD FOR
THE PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS
GENERALLY DEFINED AS THOSE THAT
LIVE TOGETHER AND PREPARE FOOD
TOGETHER. WHILE IT IS HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTAND THE HOUSEHOLD
INDIVIDUALS SUFFICIENT DATA IS
NOT CONTAINED. TO UNDERSTAND THE
RELATIONSHIP OF THE STATE OF
SUCH AS WHO'S MARRIED WHO'S THE
PARENT OF ANYONE CHILD IN THAT
HOUSEHOLD. OR TO UNDERSTAND THE
POTENTIAL TAX FILING UNIT. AND
TAXPAYERS ALSO HAVE A DECISION
TO MAKE IS HOW TO FILE FOR
EXAMPLE A SINGLE PERSON CAN FILE
A SINGLE OR HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD IF
THEY OTHERWISE MEET THE
DEFINITION. TABLING IT IS
CRITICAL TO UNDERSTAND DATA GAPS
THAT EXIST WHEN USING
INFORMATION FROM PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS IN THE
INCOME TAX PROCESS. THIS TABLE
IS BASED SOLELY ON A STUDY
RELATED TO FILERS 86% OF
HOUSEHOLDS AND CDSS DATA DID
FILE ONLY A SINGLE RETURN.
HOWEVER ONLY 62% OF THE TIME ALL
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSEHOLD WERE
ACTUALLY VISIBLE ON THE TAX
RETURN AND ONLY 57% OF THE TIME
THE DEPENDENCE IN THE HOUSEHOLD
MATCH THE DEPENDENTS CLAIMED ON
THE RETURN. WHEN FTP STUDY TO
SPECIFICALLY BALLOT SAMPLE OF
THESE FAMILIES AB ACTUALLY WAS
ABLE TO CORRECTLY CALCULATE THE
CAL E. I. T. C. CLAIMED. ON THE
FILED RETURN 37% OF THE TIME.
HAVE A TOLERANCE FOR
UNDERSTATING ARE OVERSTATING THE
CREDIT OF UP TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
EXIST SB WAS ABLE TO COMPUTE THE
CREDIT. WITHIN THIS TOLERANCE
RANGE 68% OF THE TIME. TABLE
NINE EXTRAPOLATED THESE RESULTS
FOR FILERS TO NON FILER
POPULATION. OF THE ONE POINT
FOUR FIVE MILLION SINGLE
INDIVIDUALS IDENTIFIED IN THIS
GROUP. APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
MAY HAVE QUALIFIED FOR CAL EITC
BASED ON THEIR WAGES ALONE.
AFTER HE DID NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND OF THESE
POTENTIAL FIGHTERS HAD SELF
EMPLOYMENT INCOME. THAT WOULD
HAVE POTENTIALLY REMOVE THEM
FROM QUALIFYING FOR KELLY THANK
YOU SEE. CONCEPTS MOST
IMPORTANTLY DISCUSSES THE
FEASIBILITY F USING GOVERNMENT
STUFF THAT CAN ASSIST TAXPAYERS
WITH PREPARING AND FILING A TAX
RETURN OR OTHERWISE PROVIDING
THE TAXPAYER WITH A WARM HANDOFF
TO APPLY TO STATE. A WARM HAND
OFF CAN BE ASSISTED TRACK FARE
AND MAKING AN APPOINTMENT HOW TO
FIND A LOCATION OR SIMPLY
PROVIDING THE TAXPAYER WITH
INFORMATION ON WHERE WHAT VI<c.cyan></c>
IS. AND JARIUS LOCATIONS THAT
THEY CAN ACCESS THE SERVICES.
FURTHER STUDY ILLEGAL ANALYSIS
WOULD BE NEEDED ON THIS CONCEPT.
AS THE IRS HAS STRICT RULES FOR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND LIABILITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH INDIVIDUALS. WHO
CAN PREPARE AND FILE RETURNS AND
BE PAID TO DO SO. A LEGAL
CONCERN MAY PRESENT PRESENT
SKEWS ME IF GOVERNMENTAL STAFF
ARE PAID DURING THE TIME THEY
ARE ASSISTING THE TAXPAYER
PREPARING A TAX RETURN.
ADDITIONALLY MANY VITAL SIGNS
ARE ONLY OPEN DURING TYPICAL TAX
FILING MONTHS FIRST AS YEAR
ROUND DUE TO LACK OF FUNDING.
AND VOLUNTEERS. GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES UNDER THE SECTION COULD
BE STATE OR LOCAL ENTITIES AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL AS WELL.
CONCEPT DEVELOPED OUT RICH
OPPORTUNITIES OUR STUDY FOCUSED
ON DIRECT OUTRAGE TO TAXPAYERS-
IN REGARDS TO BEING DONE BY
EITHER FTP OR OUR PEERS STATE
AGENCIES. THE SECTION DOES NOT
IN GENERAL ADDRESSED THE GENERIC
OUTREACH THAT IS CRITICAL TO
DEAL AND PERFORMED BY MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND PARTNERS. A
CRITICAL UNDERSTANDING FOR
ENGAGING AND DROPPED OUT REACHES
THAT THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
OVERLAP OF CLIENTELE AMONG THE
VARIOUS PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS AND UNDOUBTEDLY ANY
TAXPAYERS AT AFTER SHE MIGHT
REACH OUT TO AVOID TAXPAYER
CONFUSION- OVERSATURATION.
SPECIFIC COORDINATION ABOUT
REGION TASK UNDERTAKEN SHOULD
OCCUR ACTUALLY IN MANY OF OUR
PEER DEPARTMENT STAND READY TO
ENGAGE ON THIS EFFORT AND
FURTHER DISCUSSION. HERE ARE TWO
KEY ITEMS WHEN DIRECT OUT REACH
COULD BE PERFORMED MOST
SUCCESSFULLY. ON A PRE FILING OF
RETURN BASIS REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE. NINETEEN EIGHT
FIVE THREE REQUIRES EMPLOYERS
AND PUBLIC ASSISTANCE POGRAMS
TO REACH OUT ANNUALLY AND INFORM
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND PARTICIPANTS
OF THE CAL E. I. T. C. THIS
REMAINS A HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
OUTREACH PROGRAM ON A ONE TO ONE
BASIS DIRECTLY TO TAXPAYERS. BUT
WE MAY WISH TO REVIEW THE
EXISTING SUCH IT TO SEE IF IT IS
ONE TO DETERMINE IF THEY CAN BE
ENHANCED TO ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
OUTREACH EFFORTS ARE MORE
FREQUENT OUTREACH THROUGHOUT THE
FILING SEASON. HOUSE FILING ONE
AFTER RETURNS HAVE BEEN FILED
WHICH IS TYPICALLY GOING TO BE-
ON THE DUE DATE OF APRIL
FIFTEENTH TWENTY. OF ANY TALKS
HERE. AS RESOURCE RICH CAN BE
CONDUCTED ON TAXPAYERS WHO FILED
A RETURN. ELIGIBLE FOR CHALFONT
CAL THE AGENCY BUT DID NOT
CLAIM. WHICH WOULD BE OUT REACH
CONDUCTED BY F. TV. ALLEN OUT
REACH FOR NON FILERS IS ALSO
POSSIBLE WITH THOSE NON FILERS
THAT HAVE PROVEN WAGES THAT ARE
WITHIN THE QUALIFYING RANGES OF
THE CALLIE H. C. CREDIT. I'M NOT
CAN BE TOUGH CUTS DID BY VARIOUS
STATE ENTITIES INCLUDING MANY OF
THE CARE DEPARTMENTS WE WORK
WITH AN FTP. DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS WOULD BE CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT COULD BE DONE AS
WELL. ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS ARE
WARNED TO DEVELOP APPROACHES TO
DO THIS TYPE OF OUT REACH
INCLUDING DISCUSSIONS ON TIME
YOU KNOW THE OUT REACH. WHAT
EXACTLY WOULD BE MARKETED SUCH
AS KELLY IDC FEDERAL INCENTIVES
AND VITAL SERVICES. HOW AVERAGE
JUST PERFORMED TAXED CALLS
LETTERS. OPTIONS FOR ALL
TAXPAYERS CAN RESPOND TO THAT
REGION HOW TO SUPPORT TAXPAYERS
RECEIVING THESE OUTRAGE
NOTIFICATIONS. IMPORTANT GAPS TO
FOCUS ON WOULD BE ENSURING
TAXPAYERS ARE SUPPORTED
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AND NOT
LEFT WITH A SENSE OF UNEASE THAT
THIS IS A SPAM TYPE OUT REACH.
I'M TIMING WOULD ALSO BE
CRITICAL IF ANY PRE POPULATING
OF DATA IS DESIRED. BEST DATA IS
TYPICALLY NOT AVAILABLE UNTIL AT
LEAST TWELVE MONTHS AFTER THE
ORIGINAL DUE DATE OF RETURN. FOR
EXAMPLE IF A RETURN IS DUE APRIL
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE LAST
YEAR. WE WOULD JUST NOW BE
APPROACHING THE TIME FRAME WHERE
BEST DATA IS AVAILABLE TO
CONDUCT OUTREACH. WHILE OUTRAGE
COULD BE CONDUCTED EARLIER YOU
RUN THE RISK THAT ANY PRE
POPULATED DATA IS INCOMPLETE AND
INCORRECT. ON THE CREDIT COULD
BE UNDERSTATED OR OVERSTATED
PUTTING THE TAXPAYER IN AN
UNDESIRED POSITION. FINALLY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT FOR
DECADES TAX ENTITIES ACADEMIC
STUDY PARTNERS AND OTHER TRUSTED
PARTNER ENTITIES HAVE CONDUCTED
THIS TYPE OF OUTREACH. AND ALL
THOSE EFFORTS DID PRODUCE
RESULTS WHICH IS GOOD NEWS AND
GENERAL THE RESPONSE RATE WAS
TYPICALLY LESS THAN 25% AND IN
MANY OF THESE CASES LESS THAN 5%
CONCEPT EVEN LATE FOR CALIFORNIA
ISSUE IN A UNIQUE FINALLY NINETY
THAT CAN BE USED INSTEAD OF AN
I. TEN. OR THE INTERMISSION I
TEN AS BEING ISSUED BY THE IRS
WITH THE PROCESS CAN BE LENGTHY.
IMPORTANT GAPS UNDERSTAND IF
THIS CONCEPT IS FOR JUNE
PERCENT. IDENTITY THEFT IS A
CRIME A SIGNIFICANCE TODAY WITH
MANY SUGGESTING THERE ARE FEW
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE PERSONAL DATA
HAS NOT YET BEEN COMPROMISED IN
SOME WAY. ANY FUNCTION ESTABLISH
ALLOW FOR UNIQUE CALIFORNIA
IDENTIFIER WOULD NEED TO BE
PURSUED WITH CAUTION TO ENSURE
TAXPAYERS ARE NOT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED. AND STARTING THE
PROCESS OF HOW THE IRS OF
VERIFIED IDENTITY IDENTITY
EXCUSE ME AND BEST PRACTICES
ACROSS THE NATION TO IDENTIFY AN
INDIVIDUAL. AN IN PERSON
EXPERIENCE AS NECESSARY TO ALLOW
FOR THE STUDYING OF KEY CONTROL. DOCUMENTS PROVING THE PERSON'S
IDENTITY. IN LIGHT OF THIS SB
NOT READ SEEN ADVANTAGE TO
PURSUE THE ISSUE OF THE IN
HEALTH. I THE PROCESS SHOULD AN
MUST LIKELY WOULD SUBSTANTIALLY
MAYOR. THE PROCESS THE IRS
FOLLOWS THE MIDDLE TRYING.
ADDITIONALLY HAVE TO BE TO NOT
COVER HAVE SUCH OFFICE LOCATIONS
TO MANAGE SUCH A PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD MEAN WE WOULD NEED TO
PARTNER WITH STRATEGICALLY
PLACED ENTITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. WHICH COULD FOR THE
RESULT IN COST TO THE TAXPAYERS
WALLS INTRODUCED RISK TO THE
TAXPAYER FOR SITUATION OCCURRED
WHERE DATA WAS SOMEHOW
COMPROMISED. FINALLY AFTER THREE
WOULD NOT THE SOLUTION DOES NOT
RESOLVE THE NEED FOR TAXPAYER TO
FOLLOW FEDERAL RETURN TO. CLAIM
THOSE FEDERAL INCENTIVES.
CONCEPT AB INCLUDES ONE FOR THE
CONCEPT WITH THE GOVERNMENT
STUFF CAN ASSIST WITH THE
ISSUANCE OF AN ITEM. FURTHER
STUDY AND LEGAL ANALYSIS WOULD
BE NEEDED ON THIS CONCEPT AS
CYRUS AGAIN HOW STRICT AND
INFLEXIBLE RULES FOR ISSUING AN
AYE CHAN. MUST RECIPROCALLY TO
REQUEST AN ITEM FOR THE FIRST
TIME ATTRACTION GENERALLY NEEDS
TO BE FILED SIMULTANEOUSLY
WITHOUT APPLICATION. AS
DISCUSSED EARLIER IN CONCEPT SEE
A LEGAL CONCERN MAY PERCENT OF
GOVERNMENT STUFF ARE PAID DURING
THE TIME THEY ARE SEEING DOCTORS
ARE PREPARING TO TAX RETURN. OR
NIGHT TEN APPLICATIONS. SOME
VITA SITE GET WELL ASSIST.
INCOMPLETE IN THE STORE EFFORT.
HOWEVER MOST FIGHTERS TO NOT
OPEN YEAR ROUND DUE TO LACK OF
FUNDING AND VOLUNTEERS. CONCEPT
ART FOR LATE SIX EXPANSION AND
PUBLICATION OF TAX FORMS
MATERIALS IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES.
OF TV'S WEBSITE HAS OVER TWENTY
FIVE MILLION VISITORS A YEAR.
AND GENERAL FTP IS WEBSITE IS
PUBLISHED IN ENGLISH WITH SELECT
PAGES AND APPLICATIONS ALSO JUST
PLAIN IN SPANISH OR OTHER
LANGUAGES. TO MEET ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE NEEDS OF TO BE HAS
SUPPLIED GOOGLE TRANSLATE TOOL
FOR DOCTORS TO USE THAT WOULD
CONVERT MULTIPLE PORTIONS OF OUR
WEBSITE TO DISPLAY IN OVER ONE
HUNDRED DIFFERENT ONE HUNDRED
AND NINE DIFFERENT LANGUAGE
OPTIONS. THIS TOOL DOES NOT
ALWAYS CORRECTLY TRANSLATE
TECHNICAL INFORMATION THOUGH NOT
AS A CONVERT PDF DOCUMENTS TO A
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE AND FOR LONG
STANDING BUSINESS REASONS AFTER
THE ATTACK FORMS ARE GENERALLY
PUBLISHED AS PDF DOCUMENTS THAT
CAN BE DOWNLOADED. FOR USE OR
REFERENCE. THE MAJORITY OF THESE
FORMS ARE IN ENGLISH WITH SELECT
FREQUENTLY USED FORMS ALSO
PUBLISHED IN SPANISH. IMPORTANT
GAPS HUNDRED FAN OF THIS CONCEPT
IS PURSUED IS THAT HAVE TO BE IS
RETURN PROCESSING INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH SUPPORTS THE TIMELY
PROCESSING OF RETURNS AND
ISSUANCE OF REFUND FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. VERY SENSITIVE
DATA PLACE ON EACH FORM WHICH
CAN BE COMPROMISED THE FORMS ARE
SUBMITTED FOR PROCESSING IN
LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
ADDITIONALLY AFTER B. IS
CURRENTLY STRUGGLING WITH TIMELY
PUBLISHING EXISTING FORMS AN
ENGLISH TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS
NEED IN THESE FORMS TO FILE.
REQUIRING FORMS AN ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE WILL ONLY FURTHER
DECREASE OUR ABILITY TO TIMELY
POST THESE TAX FORMS.
NEVERTHELESS BOTH OF THESE
ISSUES CAN LIKELY BE MANAGED BUT
SPECIFIC ATTENTION TO THESE
MATTERS AS NECESSARY TO AVOID
UNWANTED IMPACT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. BOB ENOUGH
CONCEPTS JAN H. REALLY TO
ENHANCE FUNDING STRATEGIES FOR
OUTREACH FUNDS TO OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND
PARTNERS. THESE CONCEPTS
DOCUMENT BENEFITS AND RISKS WITH
GRANTING FUNDING ARE NOT
GRANTING ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY
GRANTING FUNDING ON GOING IN THE
STATE BUDGET. OPERATIONAL
RESTRICTIONS ARE OBSERVED WITH
THE INABILITY 2% FUNDING YEAR
OVER YEAR. AND CONTINUALLY AND
DUST OPERATION THE ABILITY TO
PERFORM CONTINUAL OUT REACH OF
MOST IMPORTANTLY YEAR ROUND TAX
FREE TAX PREPARATION SERVICES.
THANK INCREASE THANK YOU YOUR
TIME TODAY ON ALLOWING ME TO
QUICKLY SUMMARIZE THIS REPORT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT- EXTENSIVE
EXPLANATION- REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT WENT
INTO. STUDYING THE OPTIONS THAT
WE HAVE IN ORDER TO SEE IF
THERE'S A WAY FOR US TO GET THAT
KELLY ITC OUT TO AS MANY PEOPLE
AS POSSIBLE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. CENTER KAMLAGER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND YOU
KNOW I. AM ALSO ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE SO IF I'M TOGGLING
BACK AND FORTH IT'S NOT BECAUSE
I'M AN INTERESTED IT'S BECAUSE
I'M TRYING TO BE MORE THAN ONE
PLACE AT THE SAME TIME. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR- YOUR
PRESENTATION AND REALLY AS IT
RELATES TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY I
. MMHM I JUST HAVE A QUESTION
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE FROM THE
REPORT. WE'RE DOING A LOT. TO
HELP COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- AND WE'RE DOING
MORE TO HELP WITH THEM THEN WE
ARE TO HELP THOSE ELIGIBLE
HOUSEHOLDS WHO NEED THIS MONEY-
AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
BEEN PILOTING OUT. YOU KNOW YOU
BE I PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE.
WHICH ESSENTIALLY ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT PEOPLE ARE POOR ANY
KNOWLEDGE IS THAT THEY NEED
EXTRA MONEY AND IS LIKE YOU KNOW
IMPARTING SOME FAITH ON THEM TO
MANAGE THEIR FINANCES WELL WITH
THIS EXTRA INFUSION. BASED ON
DATA AND STUDIES AND PILOT
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS THAT HAS
SHOWN THAT THAT CAN BE THE CASE
. I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE
ARE ASKING FOR PEOPLE TO CHASE
MONEY THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
AND WHY WE ARE CONTINUING TO
OVER FIND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO DO WORK WHERE
WE SEE THEY'RE HAVING TROUBLE
CONNECTING TO. THESE HOUSEHOLDS
THAT NEED. THESE CREDITS IN THIS
EXTRA MONEY SO CAN WE LIKE
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO FLIP THE
SCRIPT. I'M STILL ALL TIME AND
I'M NOT SURE THAT IT'S MY- PLACE
TO REALLY DEFINITIVELY ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION- BUT THANKS FOR
THAT QUESTION. YOU KNOW SOME
GOOD POINTS- KNOWLEDGE OF THE
CREDIT. IS CERTAINLY A JOB THAT
WE'VE SEEN AND HEARD I'M TRYING
TO ADDRESS IN THIS REPORT- AND
THERE ARE ALSO A NUMBER OF
TAXPAYERS THAT WE KNOW THAT ARE
AWARE OF THE CREDIT. AND SHE'S
NOT TO CLAIM IT BECAUSE OF THE
EXPENSE AND THE BURDEN TO CLAIM
IT ON A TAX RETURN. SO- OVER THE
YEARS- IF I CAN TAKE ITBACK ON
A WALK TO TWENTY FIFTEEN AND FOR
THEIR THEIR BEEN ON AND OFF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT- WHETHER
THIS IS. IS THE RIGHT PLACE AND
THE TALKS WORLD WHERE THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT TO FILE A RETURN- DO
YOU CHANGE THE TO LEGAL
DEFINITION OF RIGHT OF RETURN
FILED IS OR THAT SOMEBODY ELSE
WILL PREPARE IT FOR YOU BUT THAT
WOULD JUST BE A CALIFORNIA ONLY
SOLUTION. WHICH DOESN'T- REALLY
GOT THE MONEY THAT'S MOST-
TREATED AT THIS TIME WHICH IS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL- AND FEDERAL
DISCUSSIONS OF COURSE AND
SOLUTIONS ARE ARE REALLY OUTSIDE
OF THE SCOPE OF CONTROL OF F. T.
B. EVEN AS WE MIGHT TRY TO
ATTEMPT TO ENGAGE THE IRS. ON
SOLUTIONS FOR THESE MATTERS. SO
I HOPE I ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION
A LITTLE BIT- I JUST DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE IS A GOOD ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION. WE DON'T. SUPPORT
LAST THING YOU SAID. BECAUSE I
LIKE HONESTY IF WE DON'T REALLY
HAVE AN ANSWER THEN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SAY THAT SO
THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CONTINUE TO DISSECT THE
CHALLENGES SO THAT WE CAN GET TO
A BETTER RESOLUTION BUT- I JUST
THINK WE DO OURSELVES A
DISSERVICE WHEN WE ARE TRYING TO
CREATE GREATER TRUST BETWEEN
CALIFORNIANS AND THE STATE. WHEN
WE MAKE IT HARD FOR FOLKS TO
HAVE ACCESS TO WHAT THEY
DESERVE- AND HOW WEEK BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW YOU CLOSE POVERTY
GAPS- AND SO YOU KNOW. ITHINK
MAYBE THAT'S OUR CHALLENGE FOR
THE YEAR FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THAT THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WHY I AM THAT'S THE REASON THAT
THE REPORT WAS COMMISSIONED- IT
WAS WE HAVE BEEN SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN OUTREACH
AND- AND I AGREE WITH YOU A 100%
WE'RE- SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY
ON OUTREACH AND NOT ENOUGH ON
GETTING. YOU KNOW THE MONEY TO
THE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY NEEDED
AND I UNDERSTAND IT I JUST LET
ME JUST SAY THAT LISTENING TO
YOU EXPLAIN THE CHALLENGES OF
EACH ONE OF THESE OPTIONS- WAS
REALLY INSTRUCTIVE. BECAUSE WHEN
YOU KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT THE
SOLUTIONS ARE EASY TO MAKE IT'S
EASY TO MAKE THEM EASY WHY CAN'T
WE JUST GET THIS MONEY INTO THE
HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE. ARE
DON'T MAKE ENOUGH MONEY. AND-
AND IT JUST SEEMS LIKE A SIMPLE
THING BUT IT'S NOT AND SO PART
OF I THINK WHAT WE HAVE TO DO.
IS LOOK AT WHAT YOU'VE OUTLINED.
AND I THINK WHAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL IS IT AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT. I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
BEYOND WHAT YOU LOOKED AT BUT-
TO TELL US WHAT WOULD IT COST.
TO DO ANY OF THESE ALTERNATIVES-
SOMEBODY INVOLVED- TECHNOLOGY
SOME OF IT INVOLVES- GETTING
PERMISSION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH MIGHT BE TOUGH
BUT IT LIST IF WE KNOW WHAT THE
COST WOULD BE WE COULD WE COULD
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHICH WHAT'S
THE DIRECTION WE NEED TO GO AND
BECAUSE I WANT AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE WE- WE REALLY WANT TO
GET. MONEY INTO THE HANDS OF
FAMILIES AT THIS CAN MAKE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE. WITH AND-
I AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
WE HAD SO MANY COMMUNITY BASED
ADVOCATES THAT WERE WILLING TO
COME TO THE TABLE AND HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
HAVING IT FOR A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME NOW AND- AND I
THINK WE NEED WE NEED SOME
SOLUTION. SOUTH THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THIS WAS FOR
INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES ONLY.
CRUCIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION TODAY. SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE. WHICH IS THE TAX
PAYMENT. FLEXIBILITY FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND
THAT'S THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO PRESENT AS WELL. I THANK YOU
THIS IS AN ECONOMIST WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE CALL
THE NINETEEN PANDEMICS NEGATIVE
ECONOMIC EFFECTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THEREFORE THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY TO THOSE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY BY ALLOWING THEM TO
DELAY THEIR TAX PAYMENTS. AND
NOT INCUR INTEREST FOR PENALTIES
RELATED TO LATE FILING FOR
PAYMENTS. IT WOULD BE OPERABLE
FOR TAX YEARS TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BECAUSE PAYMENT DUE DATES I
RELATED TO THIS TAX YEARS OR
AFTER THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
. ASSEMBLY COOLEY A SINGLE
TAXPAYERS EARNING LESS THAN
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND MARRIED FILING JOINTLY
HOUSEHOLDS EARNING LESS THAN A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WOULD HAVE UNTIL SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO
PAY THEIR TAXES FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TAX YEARS.
INTEREST IN PAYING INTEREST AND
PENALTIES WOULD BEGIN TO ACCRUE
A NEW AS OF OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE ON ANY UNPAID
BALANCE. IN SITUATIONS WHERE AN
ELIGIBLE TAXPAYER HAS ALREADY
MADE A LATE PAYMENT FOR THE
ELIGIBLE TAX YEARS. AND PAID A
LATE PENALTY OR INTEREST THE F.
T. B. I WILL AUTOMATICALLY
REFUND. THE PENALTY AND INTEREST
PAYMENTS- THANKS I'LL OPEN UP
ANY QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY THE LA-
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
HAVE NO CONCERNS AT THIS POINT-
AGAIN WAITING TO- SEE SPECIFIC
DETAILS AND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- ONE COMMENT BOB. WHAT
I'M SURE OBVIOUSLY THAT- TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IS CONSISTENT WITH
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SCHOOLS OF
TARGETING- THE DEFERRAL OPTION-
BUT WE'LL SEE WHEN THE TRAILER
BILL COMES OUT WILL BE WORKING
WITH YOUR STAFF. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AT QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM SO
WE'LL WAIT TO SEE THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AS WELL. MAKE SURE
IT STAFF. DOES IT WE THINK IT
SHOULD DO. WAY TO MOVE ON TO
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO.
WHICH IS THE INNOVATION
HEADQUARTERS CREDIT AGAIN THE
PRESENTATION IS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIS IS
NICK THOMAS AGAIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
INNOVATION HEADQUARTERS CREDIT
WOULD BE IN PLACE FROMTWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND WILL PROVIDE A
NEW RESEARCH CREDIT FOR
COMPANIES INVESTING ACTIVITIES
AND TECHNOLOGIES THAT MITIGATE
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ARE
HEADQUARTERED IN CALIFORNIA. THE
CREDIT WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND
WOULD TARGET A REVENUE LOSS OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR- THIS PROPOSAL
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANT ROLE OF
RESEARCH. AND INNOVATION IN
CONFRONTING THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND THIS ONE IN A SERIES OF
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS. THANKS OPEN UP ANY
QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD- COMMENTS
FROM THE L. A. O. YES THIS IS
BRIAN WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND- WE DON'T HAVE ANY COMMENT
ON THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO-
DEVALUATION OF ITS DETAILS.
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. YES THE CAMERA
YES SO I THINK I HAVE THE SAME
QUESTION NGUYEN AND HOW WILL
THIS GET FLUSHED OUT- BECAUSE
IT'S- INTERESTING INTRIGUING AND
- J. YEAH THIS IS THOMAS WITH
FINANCE- WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF WORKING OUT A NUMBER
OF DETAILS RELATED TO THIS
PROPOSAL- AND WE EXPECT SAID HOW
THIS LANGUAGE AVAILABLE IN A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY WORKING- WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH OTHERS AS WELL
AS WE DEVELOP THOSE DETAILS.
INCLUDING CRITERIA. YES THANK
YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS. I DO I
DO HAVE- LET ME JUST SAY THAT TO
THE EXTENT THAT. I THINK IT'S
BEING DEVELOPED- I MIGHT MY TWO
CENTS WORTH IS- AND I THINK I MY
BIGGEST CONCERN WITH IT IS THAT
IN YEARS PAST. THIS WOULD HAVE
BEEN PUT IN A BUDGET BUT THE
POLICY WOULD HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
BE CARRIED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND- THE REASON THAT BECOMES
IMPORTANT IS THEN WE HAVE INPUT
INTO WHAT. WHAT ARE THE KINDS OF
TAX CREDIT IF WE'RE GONNA DO
CREDITS- THAT THAT- THAT MAKE
MAJOR INVESTMENTS IN OUR ECONOMY
WHICH IS USUALLY WHAT TAX
CREDITS ARE ALL ABOUT WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. NUMBER ONE THAT
IT WILL ACHIEVE GOALS THAT WE
SET UP WERE VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT
THOSE GOALS NUMBER TWO THAT
EVERY REGION IN THE STATE CAN
PARTICIPATE IN. IN HAVING THE
TAX CREDIT IN THE COMMUNITY SO
THAT THEY'RE CREATING JOBS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY- AND WE TEND TO
SEE THAT THE TAX CREDITS GO.
FIVE WEALTHIER COMMUNITIES THAT
ALREADY HAVE A GOOD JOB BASE AND
SO- SO MY COURT MY BIG QUESTION
IS WHAT IS THE ANTICIPATED GOAL
WE'RE TRYING TO REACH AND I KNOW
IT'S A- IT IS. TO MITIGATE
CLIMATE CHANGE. BUT AS WE START
TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT OF. SHEPHERDING IN OUR
SOLAR ENERGY AND ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND YET WE- WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE KINDS OF JOBS THAT
ARE CREATED- IF YOU PUT SOLAR ON
YOUR RESIDENCE NONE OF THE
PANELS COME FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YET WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE PANELS AND SO
WHY AREN'T WE USING A TAX
CREDIT. TO BUILD- SOLAR PANELS
THEY GET USED ON THE HOMES IN
OUR OWN STATE IF WE'RE GOING TO
PRIORITIZE. ELECTRIC BUSES WHICH
IS ONE OF THE AGENDA ITEMS FOR
THE BUDGET IS TO START FOCUSING
ON. ELECTRIC BUSES AND I BELIEVE
IT IF I RECALL IT WAS FOR
SCHOOLS. IT'S A TERRIFIC GOAL
IT'S WONDERFUL I SUPPORTED BUT
WHY AREN'T WE BUILDING I'M HERE
IN THE STATE CALIFORNIA AND IF
WE ARE GOING TO BUILDING HERE.
THEN THE TAX CREDIT OUT TO GO TO
MEET THE GOALS OF THOSE BUSES
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
PURCHASING HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I'D LIKE TO THINK
THAT WE CAN- FOCUS ON
MANUFACTURING JOBS IN THE STATE
WHICH WE'VE LOST OVER THE YEARS.
AND WHICH WOULD READ IT REALLY
BENEFIT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
COMMUNITIES IN. A CUP-
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DESPERATE
FOR GOOD JOBS. AND THAT ARE
HAVING A CHALLENGE BECAUSE-
THEY'RE NOT COMING TO OUR
COMMUNITY SO. THIS IS A HOLLOW
OPEN ITEM I AM HOPING THAT AS WE
LOOK TO- INVESTMENTS IN IN TO
MITIGATE CLIMATE CHANGE THAT WE
ALSO LOOK AT JOB CREATION AND
THE ABILITY FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THIS TRANSITION TO. TO TO
JOBS AT THAT ARE DESPERATELY
NEEDED IN MANY OF OUR COMMUNITY
SO- AGAIN THIS IS A HOLD OPEN
ITEM. MORE ON THAT LATER BECAUSE
WE JUST DON'T HAVE ANY
INFORMATION ON THAT. ARE MOVING
ON WE'RE GOING TO- MOVE ON TO
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION THIS
IS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE.
WHICH IS THE- REMOVAL OF
PROVISION ONE POSITION CONTROL
AND THIS IS. IN THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION. YES. SO IF
I'M IF I COULD TURN THE MIKE
OVER TO. THE DEPARTMENT. CORRECT
BURKE SENTENCED PARKER TO
FINANCE. THE LEGISLATURE- I HAD
A PROVISION ONE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
SUPPORT ITEMS BACK IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AS RESPONSE
THAT. A REVENUE GENERATING
POSITIONS WERE BEING REDIRECTED
TO NON REVENUE GENERATING
WORKLOADS THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES REMOVING THE PROVISION
ONE LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT HINDERS
THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFICIENCIES
AND THE ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
NEW WORKLOADS AND OTHER ISSUES.
WITH US TODAY WE HAVE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THE CD TFA
AND BE WE TO ADD. TO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ABOUT VERSION ONE AND
THE IMPACTS TO THESE TAX
AGENCIES I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST.
START WITH I JEANNIE HERMAN AT
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD FROM
BACKGROUND TO DISCUSSION ON THE
PROVISION ONE. THANK STARK FELL-
YES SO HAPPY TO DISCUSS THIS AND
ACTUALLY BE WRITTEN OUT THE- THE
SUPPORT FOR REMOVING THIS
LANGUAGE- WE ARE AN ORGANIZATION
BACK IS VERY AWARE OF OUR
COMMITMENTS AND GOALS GETTING
WORK DONE- AND WE GO ON ABOUT
AND BEYOND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN DO IT. OVER THE YEARS
PROVISION ONE WHICH HAS BEEN N
PLACE- I'LL DESCRIBE IT IS IT
WAS REALLY PUTTING BECAUSE THAT
REALLY DRIVES IT HOME WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT HOW IT WAS DONE. IN
THE VERY. LATE NINETIES- WITH AN
R. OR- AND AUDITOR THAT WORKS
WITH A TAXPAYER CONSIDERED
PROVISION ONE. HOWEVER AN
AUDITOR THAT USES A MAIL ROOM TO
ISSUE A NOTICE OR USES
TECHNOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING
OR NEEDS TO GO TO TRAINING OR
NEEDS TO BE MANAGED NONE OF
THOSE OUTLINE ACTIVITIES WHICH
ARE NECESSARY FOR THE AUDITOR TO
BE- ADDITION AND EFFECTIVE AT
WHAT THEY DO ARE CONSIDERED
PROVISION ONE. BY THE TIME YOU
LOOK AT ALL OF THOSE ANCILLARY
ACTIVITIES THAT SUPPORT THAT
HONOR HE ALMOST ARE NOT AN
ORGANIZATION THAT'S ENTIRELY
PROVISION ONE WHICH FOR THE
NEGATES THE NEED FOR THAT TYPE
OF A PROVISION IN PLACE. NEVER
THE LESS OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE
BEEN- REMINDED THAT- AUTRES OUR
AUDITORS ON THEIR PART A
PROVISION ONE COLLECTORS BY
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS ARE PART OF
PROVISION ONE- AND THOSE OTHER
FOLKS ARE NOT. WITH THE WAY THAT
WE CONDUCT OUR BUSINESS
OPERATIONS TODAY- BECAUSE OF THE
TRYING TO THE TIME OR BECAUSE OF
OUR EDR PROJECT- AND NOW EASIER
TO YOU. WE ARE VERY
COMPREHENSIVE SPIDER WEB OF
FUNCTIONS THAT ALL WORK OGETHER
SUCCESSFULLY OR NOT WORK
TOGETHER SUCCESSFULLY. SO- BUT A
KEY EXAMPLE AGAIN THAT I CAN
POINT OUT IN RECENT YEARS WHEN
EDR CAME FORWARD TRAINING WAS A
JOB THAT WE HAD MISSED AND AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW MUCH
TRAINING WAS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT WITH A MASSIVE CHANGES
WE WERE DEALING. SO PER TRAINING
IS NOT CONSIDERED PROVISION ONE.
THAT SHOULD BE DID NOT PUT
ADEQUATE RESOURCE TEAM FORWARD
AND BCPS SO THIS DEPARTMENT WE
STRUGGLED WITH FINDING
RESOURCES. THAT COULD BE
REDIRECTED TO TRAIN ALL OF OUR
STUFF- AND IN SOME SITUATIONS WE
SUCCEEDED IN OTHERS WE DIDN'T
RESULTING IN LOSS OF RETRAINING
EFFORTS THAT NEEDED TO HAPPEN
AND STOCKS THAT REALLY STRUGGLE
TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE THE NEW
TOLLS- MAS OF LESSONS LEARNED
SO- IN CLOSING I WOULD JUST SAY
OF TO BE WOULD VERY MUCH SUPPORT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
OPTIMIZE OUR- ACTIONS AND OUR
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR RESOURCE GAPS
THE PRESENT AND THE DEPARTMENT
THAT COULD NOT OTHERWISE BE
TIMELY SOLVED BY A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
MUCH. THIS IS DARK SINISTER AND
FINANCE WE HAVE JASON FROM
TEACHING BAY TO DISCUSS SOME OF
THE IMPACTS THEIR AT THE TV
TAMPAK. SURE THANK YOU DEREK AND
JUST- I CONTINUE OFF OF WHAT AND
SHE HAD SAID I'M HONEST BEHIND-
PROVISIONAL ONE IS THAT YOU CAN
THERE'S A YOU CAN DISTINGUISH
REVENUE MAKING FROM NON REVENUE
MAKING POSITIONS AND I THINK IN
REALITY. ALL FUNCTIONS PLAY A
ROLE IN- IN GENERATING REVENUE
WE JUST GIVE YOU TWO EXAMPLES OF
ONE IS OUR DATA SCIENTISTS- AND
I WOULD ASSUME IT'S THE SAME ON
THAT THE- WE HAVE TO BE OUR DATA
SCIENTISTS TODAY ARE CONSIDERED
NON REVENUE MAKING- BUT- THEY
ACTUALLY DO A LOT OF- WORK THAT
DOES. GENERATE REVENUE FOR
EXAMPLE THEY IDENTIFY
NONCOMPLIANCE WHICH DENSER AS
LEADS FOR AUDITORS TO GO ON FIND
MORE MONEY ANOTHER EXAMPLE I
THINK SIMILAR TO A GENIUS THAT
IS OUR AUDIT SUPERVISORS ARE
CONSIDERED NON REVENUE MAKING
TODAY- OF COURSE THEY'RE
ESSENTIAL FOR AUDITS- BECAUSE-
ON DAYS LIKE BUSINESSES TO ON
IT- THEY REVIEW AUDITS- AND SO
THERE ARE OTHER EXAMPLES AS WELL
BUT BASICALLY. PROVISIONAL ONE I
THINK THE PROMISE ON THIS NOT AS
RELEVANT TODAY AS IT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN IN THE PAST AND IT DOESN'T
HE GIVE BILITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. ALLOCATE RESOURCES
EFFECTIVELY. THANK YOU JASON AND
FINALLY WE HAVE BRENDA FLEMING.
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE RURAL
AND MEMBERS OF THE SISTINE
COMMITTEE I AM BRENDA FLEMING
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
STATE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION I'M
JOINED TODAY BY ONE OF MY
MANAGERS- CHIEF OF OUR SUPPORT
SERVICES DIVISION IS CATHY
TAYLOR. I CONSISTENT WITH MY
WITH MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
INDICATED THAT IS A PART OF THE
OTHER STATE TAX AGENCIES BE WE
SUPPORT. THE REMOVAL OF THE
PROVISION ONE BUDGET LANGUAGE.
THE BILL WE IS THE ONLY ALEXIS
TAX BOARD IN THE COUNTRY
COMPRISED OF FOUR EQUALIZATION
DISTRICT MEMBERS AND THE STATE
COMPTROLLER. THE BILL WE IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THREE TAX PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO OUR STATE. PROPERTY
TAX THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE TAX
AND THE TAX ON INSURERS. AND
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY THE STATE STATE
BUT NEXT STATEWIDE ASSESSED
VALUE WISE SIX POINT EIGHT
TRILLION DOLLARS RESULTING AND
SEVENTY FIVE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS A PROPERTY TAX LEVIES.
THOSE PROPERTY TAX LEVIES
CONTRIBUTED FORTY POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO SCHOOLS AND
THIRTY FOUR POINT. NINE BILLION
DOLLARS TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. A
YEAR THE BEING WE STEPS VALUES
OF AS PROPERTIES PRIMARILY
PRIVATELY OWNED PUBLIC UTILITIES
REGULATED RAILROADS AND
INTERCOUNTY PIPELINES. AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE VALUES ARE
SET AT A HUNDRED NINETEEN POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS WHICH
PRODUCED MEMBERS ONE POINT EIGHT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES. IN
ADDITION BE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
TAX PROGRAM PRODUCED THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY NINE NINE DOLLARS
AND A TAX ON INSURANCE PROGRAM
ADDED TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS TO THE GENERAL FUND. YOU
WE RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE
MAJORITY OF OUR TAX PROGRAM
MEMBERS CONSIST OF POLICY
ADMINISTRATION OVERSIGHT MANAGER
TOREY FUNCTIONS. HOWEVER OUT OF
ALL MEMBERS OUT OF APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED AGENCY POSITIONS
CURRENTLY A BE A WEEK. EIGHTY
EIGHT ARE ALLOCATED AS
PROVISIONAL POSITIONS IN OUR
PROPERTY TAX DEPARTMENT. THE
EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY INFORMATION
ON POSITIONS PROVIDE A WIDE
RANGE OF DUTIES MUCH OF WHICH
ARE NOT REVENUE GENERATING. THIS
DEMONSTRATES ARTICLE MEMBERS THE
GAP BETWEEN SPECIFIC DEPARTMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES IN RELATION TO
THE PROVISIONAL AND DESIGNATION.
THE REMOVAL OF THE PROVISION ON
REQUIREMENTS WHAT CONTRIBUTE TO
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES AS MY
COLLEAGUE THE MEDICATED AND
REDUCE THE OVERHEAD COSTS
CONNECTED TO MANAGING
PROVISIONAL ON POSITIONS AND
REMOVING THOSE CONSTRAINTS. TO
CONCLUDE SINCE MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUES OF WELL DESCRIBE SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES WHAT IT TO
CONCLUDE THIS BUDGET POLICY
CHANGE WHAT FURTHER ASSESS THE
B. WE ANY OTHER AGENCIES AND FOR
FAILING OUR OUR DUTIES FOR THE
B. AWAY CONSTITUTIONAL AND
STATUTORY DUTIES AND OUR
MISSION. WHICH IS TO SERVE
CALIFORNIANS THROUGH FAIR
ADMINISTRATION AND SUPPORT OF
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THANK YOU. MEMBERS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. YOU SECOND
CONCLUDES THE DEPARTMENTS-
RECITATION YES WE'D BE GLAD TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE VERY GOOD JOB LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. HIS
GRANDMOTHER LET ME LET ME ASK I
WAS THAT THE PRESENTATION NO
THAT WASN'T- EXCUSE ME WE GOTTA
GO BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ANY COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. BY YEAR ON MUTE YOU'RE ON MUTE
STILL. WE NEED I AM SORRY YEAH
THAT THAT CONCLUDES OUR
PRESENTATION TODAY WOULD BE GLAD
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS VERY
GOOD HOW ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. YES THIS IS
BRIAN WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND- YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENTS
DESCRIBED THE ISSUES THAT ARE
INVOLVED VERY WELL. NO WE JUST
REITERATED LANGUAGE LIKELY DOES
REDUCE THE FLEXIBILITY AND
THAT'S FLEXIBILITY THAT MOST
OTHER DEPARTMENTS ENJOY. SO WE
DON'T HAVE A RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS ITEM BUT IF YOU HAVE
RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE REMOVAL
OF THE POVISION ONE LANGUAGE WE
CAN WORK WITH YOUR STAFF. TO
EXPLORE ALTERNATIVE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT ADDRESSES THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONCERNS WHILE
ALSO- YOU KNOW PERHAPS SAID
ALLOWING GREATER FLEXIBILITY
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE THE
DEPARTMENTS. VERY GOOD ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER KAMAGRA THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I WOULD CERTAINLY BE
INTERESTED IN THE L. A. O.'S-
ALTERNATIVE RECOMMENDATIONS. I
AFTER LISTENING TO THE
PRESENTATIONS OF COURSE I AM ALL
FOR US FINDING WAYS TO GET THE
MONEY- THROUGH TAX COLLECTIONS.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW AS WE ARE
ALL LOOKING AT HOW PEOPLE DO
WORK AND HOW FOLKS CAN DO WORK
MORE EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
. YOU KNOW I'M- ALSO INTERESTED
IN MAKING SURE THAT THERE ARE
SOME CHECKS AND BALANCES WITH
REGARDS TO HOW WE'RE ADDRESSING
FLEXIBILITY HOW WE'RE
MAINTAINING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
HOW WE'RE NOT SORT OF OFFERING
GREATER AUTHORITY TO
DEPARTMENTS- WITHOUT THE
NECESSARY CHECKS AND BALANCES-
SO I SO I WOULD WELCOME THE
ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS THAT THE L.
A. O. IS. A WILLING TO PRODUCE
FOR US. VERY GOOD ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS I WANNA I
WANNA SECOND DENT THAT- COMMENT-
NO QUESTIONS. NO QUESTION THAT
WE WANT THE DEPARTMENT TO HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY TO START
PERFORMING THE NEW DUTIES THAT
WE'VE- DETERMINED ARE IMPORTANT-
AND THERE'S NO REASON IT NEW
TASK FOR SHOULD BE UNNECESSARILY
DELAYED. OUT BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THIS- PROVISION
ONE- PROCESS JUST REQUIRES A
LETTER TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND TO ME THAT DOESN'T SEEM
OVERLY BURDENSOME BUT IF THERE'S
SOME THAT IF THERE ARE
ALTERNATIVES- I APPLIED THE L.
A- FOR- HIT THE SUGGESTION THAT
WE TAKE A LOOK AT. ADD ON TRYING
TO SEE IF THERE'S A BETTER WAY
TO DO THINGS AND MORE THAT WE
CAN STREAMLINE HOW WE WORK AND
GIVE FLEXIBILITY THAT'S GOOD
BUT- I THINK THERE WAS A REASON
THIS WAS IMPOSED IN THE FIRST
PLACE WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE WE'RE NOT GETTING. JUST
GETTING RID OF IT- FOR NO REASON
SO- THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ITEMS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HOLD OPEN
AND WE'LL WE'LL SEE THE LANGUAGE
BACK AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN. COME
TO AN AGREEMENT ON ON HOW THAT-
SHOULD BE MANAGED. SO WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC.
COMMENT SECTION. OF OUR MEETING-
WE WILL MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS SEVEN SIX. TWO TWO. FOUR
SIX TWO. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARING
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS ME
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO ASK
EACH MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
PROVIDING COMMENT KEEP THEIR
REMARKS WITHIN ONE MINUTE. NOW
LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT. SAYING
NINE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE WE CAN
BEGIN. UNLADEN GERMAN ON THE
PHONE LINE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT
THE TIME WE DO OF ABOUT NINE IN
OUR QUEUE FOR COMMENTS. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL CONTINUE.
ABSOLUTELY WE WILL START WITH
NUMBER SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE MAKE
SURE NOT ON MUTE. HELLO YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. HI MY NAME IS A
UNIQUE DUNLAP. AND. I AM A
CURRENT FOSTER YOUTH FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY COUNTY CALLING
AT THE PORT OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
PROPOSAL AND- INCLUDING NEW
THOUSAND DOLLARREFUNDABLE TAX
CREDIT FOR THE FORMER FOSTER
pSUPPORT THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET FROM- CAL
COLLATION COUNTY T. C.
CORRELATION. AND THANK YOU VERY
IMPORTANT COURT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL TO
NUMBER TWENTY TWO. AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ANNA
THOMPSON WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL FOR
FOSTER YOUTH TAX CREDIT IN THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT I
EXPANDED ITEMS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS TODAY AROUND
INNOVATION AND HOW TO. DECREASE
POVERTY AMONG FOSTER YOUTH WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE.
TEXAS NUMBER SIXTEEN. HI MY NAME
IS CODY VAN HELDEN I AM A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH FROM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE A
NEW ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT FOR FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH I WANT TO THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR YOUR SUPPORT I AM
ALSO A NEW MOTHER WENT IN EIGHT
MONTHS OLD SO I AM CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT GLOBAL THEN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON THE EITC
COALITION AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING TODAY.
NEXT PLEASE. WELL NOW GO TO
NUMBER NINETEEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS CHRISTINA TOWARDS AROUND THE
FORMER HE'S FROM KERN COUNTY. I
AM CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE A
NEW THOUSAND REFUNDABLE TAX
PRAYER WILL NOT COST YOU. RIGHT
COULD MAKE A BIG GET RIGHT AGE
HERE AND CORN CURRENT WASHY
BECAUSE HELPS WITH THE ABILITY
I'M A FORMER THESE. AND THE IS
VERY TO AT THIS MOMENT THAT'S
WHAT I REALLY BE HELP. OR YOU OR
WORKING EXTRA INCOME THAT'LL BE
ABLE TO HELP THEM. BUT I AM A
MOTHER AS WELL- I YOU HAVE THREE
CHILDREN SO I'M ALSO INCLUDING
THE PORT OF THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT PROPOSAL IN AN APARTMENT
BUDGET BALL IN THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND EVERYTHING THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE DONE THANK YOU. SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT AT
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT. AND MARK
STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ITEMS
THIRTEEN AND FOURTEEN MUCH OF
THE ADDITIONAL STAFFING FIRST
BILL SAID LACK ANTI CAC- WITH A
GREATER NUMBER OF AWARDS AND A
HIGHER LEVEL OF COMPETITION AT
THE THAT OF BLACK HAVING THIS
ADDITIONAL STAFF WILL REALLY
MAKE THE PROCESS SMOOTHER AND
BENEFIT ALL OF OUR EFFORTS TO.
MAKE REFORM HOUSING CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER TWENTY NINE. HI MY NAME
IS JOE NINE ONE ONE AND I AM A
CURRENT I AM A FORMER FOX NEWS
FROM- LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF ARCH. CALLING
ON THE COURT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL COULD INCLUDE A NEW ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR REFUNDABLE TAX
CREDIT FORMER FOX NEWS BUT
CRITICAL MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE
FOR TRUMP'S AGE CURRENT AND
FORMER BOSS USED BECAUSE- THE
EIGHTEEN B. WILL HELP SHOOT ME
THEIR BASIC NEEDS. ALSO I'VE
DONE SOME. IDENTITY EARLY AT
PEOPLE YOU CAR ALL HAS BRENT AND
AT A DISADVANTAGE PLEASE RECORD
FONG YOU'D BETTER MUCH DESERVED
OF THE BAN. I AM ALL AND OF THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT PROPOSAL
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND ON
THE COUNT YET NEED COLLISION
THANK YOU SO MUCH EVERYONE AND
SPECIAL THANK YOU. ANOTHER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR- TODAY.
NEXT NEXT IS GOING TO BE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN. COMMAND CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME'S JACQUELINE US HUMAN
NATURE AND CONFERENCE SENTENCES
GO CATCH FROM ONE FORTY FIVE
YEARS IN THE HEART OF CHILD CARE
EARLY EDUCATION SAN FRANCISCO
RIDING HOME BASED CHILD CARE
BUSINESS IS THE TRAINING AND
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO SUCCEED.
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
END CHILD POVERTY COALITION THE
CALATHEA APC COALITION WHICH I'M
GOING TO THE GOVERNOR'S. I JUST
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT TO
KEEP PACE WITH INFLATION THE
ELIMINATION OF THE WORKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CHILDREN ZERO
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS BENEFIT FROM
THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT.
LEGISLATION TO BUILD I'M
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BY PREVENTING
A GOVERNMENT THAT INTERSECTIONS
OR AMONG. CHILD TAX CREDIT
CLAIMS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NEXT PLEASE. NEXT IS
GOING TO BE NUMBER FOURTEEN SHE
- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NEW THE MEDIA AT NINE IS
COMMON WITH PETER LOWER ESCORT
THE FOUNDATION ARE WORKING HERE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND OUR
CALL HERE ALSO SUPPORT OF OUR IN
CHILD POVERTY COALITION IN THE
KALYANJI COALITION. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE THE NEW
REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT FOR FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND ADJUSTING THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT TO KEEP
PACE WITH INFLATION AS WELL AS
THE ELIMINATION OF. WORK
REQUIREMENTS FOR CHILDREN IN
JAIL INCOME HOUSEHOLDS TO
BENEFIT FROM THE- YOUNG CHILD
TAX CREDIT WELL SURGEON ARE
LEGISLATION TO BUILD UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BY PREVENTING
GOVERNMENT DEBT INTERCESSIONS
FOR YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT
CLAIMANTS AND BERMAN THE
INCREASING AND CALIFORNIA ARE
YOU COMPACT CREDIT MINIMAL FOR
ALL TAX FILERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. THANKS WILL BE NUMBER.
TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS TERRY
ONLY WITH ECONOMIC SECURITY
PROJECT ACTION AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALLIE ATP COALITION AND
CHILD POVERTY COALITION ALSO AT
THE PORT OF THE PROPOSALS TO
ELIMINATE EARNINGS REQUIREMENT
TO KEEP KEEP PACE WITH INFLATION
FOR THE YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT.
AS WELL AND ALSO THE-
INSTITUTING A NEW THOUSAND
DOLLAR REFUNDABLE CREDIT FOR
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IT IS REALLY
EXCITING TO SEE BOTH OF THESE
PROPOSALS THAT INVEST IN
POPULATIONS THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
POVERTY- ALL THE ONES THEY JUST
DIDN'T THEY MEDICARE WITH
RESPECT TO THE Y. C. T. C. I
JUST REALLY WANT TO APPLAUD ON
THE GOVERNOR AND THE COMMITTEE
FOR SUPPORTING- MAKING
CALIFORNIA A LEADER IN
RECOGNIZING THAT YOUNG CHILDREN
THE COURT REGARDLESS OF THEIR
PARENTS EARNING SH AND THAT
CARING FOR YOUNG CHILDREN IS IN
ITSELF WORK- AND THAT CARE
GIVERS OF BEES YOUNG CHILDREN
OFTEN HAVE TO DROP OUT OF THE
FORMALLY CONNIE BECAUSE THE CARE
GIVING RESPONSIBILITIES SO. IT'S
REALLY- THAT BIGGER ISSUE-
FINALLY I A ONE SAY THAT
ELIMINATING EARNINGS
REQUIREMENTS- I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING YOU REALLY CARE ABOUT
MADAM CHAIR MAKES GETTING THE
CREDIT EASIER FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE A HARD TIME DOCUMENTING
YOUR INCOMES WHICH WE KNOW IS
TRUE FOR A LOT OF LOW WAGE
WORKERS WHO MIGHT HAVE. THAT
WORK AND THEN YOU KNOW THAT'S A
REAL PROBLEM FOR HOUSEHOLDS
WITH- LOW WAGES FINALLY I LIKE
TO WORK YOU RECOMMEND- ADDING ON
A BUILDING ON TV X. ED PROPOSAL
. ELIMINATING THE INTERSECTION-
PROBLEM WITH THE MANAGEMENT
YOUNG HEALTH TECH CREDIT AND
CREATING A MINIMUM YET CREDIT
AND FINALLY SORRY WE'RE NOT
HELPING I WILL WANT TO THANK
FRANCHISE BOARD FOR THE WAY THEY
ON IT SB PARKING ON REPORT- WELL
THERE'S WE TOO MUCH TO GET INTO
HERE- LOOK FORWARDTO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH AGENCY AND WITH
YOUR- AND OTHERS TO. GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF WHAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING A
TAX CREDIT THE ELIGIBLE FOR I
KNOW WE'RE ALL ALIGNED ON THAT
IN A LARGE THAT YOU WORK AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE
. NEXT WE'LL GO TO NEW. THIRTY
HELLO THE IS K. IN CO DIRECTOR
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATURE- CAL WE ARE AND SO
OF THE- FOR REFUNDABLE CREDIT
FOR MY LAST YOU ARE IN OF THE
CHEN THE YOUNG CHILD TAX TO KEEP
PAYING WITH AND ELEVEN WORK
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT CHILDREN IN
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS COULD
BENEFIT FROM THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER THIRTY
TWO. AFTERNOON MEDICARE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ALEXIS AND I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN ADVOCATE
IN SACRAMENTO CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL COULD
PUT A NEW REFUNDABLE TAX CREDIT
PERFORMANCE OFFER YOU. WITH
SUPPORT WAS CRUCIAL.
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT SHOULD THE
CITY USE FACE DAY TO DAY.
ADDITIONALLY I SUPPORT YOUNG
CHILD TAX ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR
BUDGET FROM THE HEALTHCARE KELLY
I COLLISION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
- SUPPORT AND FOR THAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. X. PLEASE. WE'LL GO
TO NUMBER THIRTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ON A-
COMMUNITIES CALLING IN WITH HEAD
START CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THE END CHILD POVERTY COALITION
COUNTY I KEEP THE COALITION- AND
HEADSTART CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY
WE SERVE ON SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE- FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN ON
BOARD LIVING IN IN PRETTY SEVERE
POVERTY INCLUDING DOCTOR USE AT
HOME LAST YEAR. I.
ORANGE-COUNTY-REGISTER-TOO-SOON-COUNTY-VOTE-CENTERS
AND THE ELIMINATION OF WORKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CHILDREN WOULD
BE IN ZERO INCOME HOUSEHOLDS- WE
ALSO READ THE LEGISLATURE TO
BUILD UPON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BY PREVENTING THE GOVERNMENT'S
DEBT INTERSECTIONS FOR THE YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT CLAIMANTS AND
CURRENTLY INCREASING THAT HOW
THE IDEA BEING OUT ON CALL TAX
FILERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOUR TEST. NEXT
THANKS NUMBER. THIRTY FOUR. IF
AN INDEPENDENT POLICY ASSOCIATE
AT GREAT AND TOPKAPI CALIFORNIA
ALTHOUGH PART OF THAT AND CHILD
POVERTY COALITION AND HOW THE
ATC COLLISION AND THE ECHO ALL
THE STOCK ON THE THREE COUPLES
ABOUT YOUR EXCITED TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDED HIS OPTIMAL
BUDGET HOWEVER WE INCREDIBLE
INSPECTION TO GO FURTHER BY
PREVENTING THE COLLECTION OF
GOVERNMENT DEBT WHAT BOTHERS
COMMITTEE ON CREDIT AS YOU KNOW
WHAT IT IS A TEN PEOPLE WERE
ELIGIBLE TO BENEFIT. FROM THE
TAX CREDIT OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND YOUNG TEN ARE WOMEN BY WOMEN
THAT ON THE PART OF BECAUSE THEY
THAT FOR OUR CALLED WEALTH GAP
AND EXCITED HE ON THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE THAT WE ALSO
URGE BIG TO MAKE IMPROVED IN A
PROBABLY A BY PERMANENTLY THE
MINIMUM CREDIT- FALL BACK FILERS
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH READING
JERRY MEMBERS AND LOOK FOR TO
WORKING YOUR COME REPORT. UNDER
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET THE
MANAGER. VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. NEXT PLEASE. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. VERY
GOOD CAN YOU MAKE THE ADVISEMENT
ONE MORE TIME AND THEN WILL
CONCLUDE OUR OUR HEARING.
ABSOLUTELY AND IF ANYBODY WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN Q. VERY GOOD MISTER MODERATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE HERE TODAY AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF YOU WHO
TESTIFIED- WE HEAR YOU AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING A
PART OF THIS PROCESS- MEMBERS-
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT YOU LIKE TO MAKE
IT THIS TIME. OKAY VERY GOOD-
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE VOTE
ONLY ONLY CALENDAR- I WE NEED A
MOTION FOR THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR ISSUE ITEMS ON NUMBER
ONE AND THREE THROUGH ELEVEN. SO
I'LL MAKE THAT MOTION. AND WILL
CALL A VOTE ON THAT ON THOSE
ITEMS. SENATOR CAFIERO I.
SENATOR NIELSEN. THE ROAD IS TWO
TWO ZERO AND WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN. FOR CENTER KAMLAGER TO
JOIN US- THEN WE'RE MOVING ON TO
THE REMAINING VOTE ONLY CALENDAR
ITEM ISSUE WHICH IS A MOTION ON
THE CALENDAR ISSUE ITEM NUMBER
TWO I WILL MOVE THAT AS WELL.
AND ASK FOR A VOTE ON THAT
CALENDAR ITEM. THAT ARE COMING
ERA BY SENATOR NIELSEN. THAT
MOTION DATA ITEM HAS ONE I WON
NO AND SO WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL
AS WELL. AND- WELL WAIT FIRST
SENATOR KAMLAGER TO APPEAR.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A REAL QUICK
RECESS SO THAT WE CAN WAIT.
SO
WELCOME TO THE- BUDGET SUB FOR.
COMMITTEE HEARING AND WE HAVE
HAD MOTIONS ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS MOVE BACK TO THE VOTE ON THE
COUNTER WE ADDED I AM MOTION ON
THE VOTE- NAY CALENDAR ISSUES
ONE AND THREE THROUGH ELEVEN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR COME LONGER HI.
THAT MOTION IS- THREE EYES NOSE
ZERO- THE THOSE PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE ONE REMAINING
ITEM WHICH IS A MOTION ON THE
VOTE ON THE CALENDAR ISSUE ITEM
NUMBER TWO THAT THE MOTION WAS
AND I'VE- MOTION. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT ARE COMMON FIND.
THAT MOTION PASSES TO I WANT TO
KNOW- AND DOES SO THAT CONCLUDES
VERY MUCH- ALL PARTICIPANTS
PARTICIPATING MEMBERS HAVING
VOTED I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION TODAY.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR FEEL FREE TO
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL RECORD
OF THE HEARING THANK YOU AND WE-
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING THE SENATE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
NUMBER FOUR IS AT YOUR END.